I've been in business for 13 years and
since 2020 three of the companies I
started have reached $100 million plus
valuation here's nobas advice to help
you crush 2025 my first piece of advice
is set fewer goals and do less long-term
planning hear me out and so this may
sound contradictory to some of my
content about being patient and I think
long-term goals are very important but
the obsession over the minutia of how
you're going to get there is I believe
an act of mental masturbation you try
and create these massive projections
that are based on hundreds of variables
that in reality you just don't know
what's going to happen and so over time
I've consistantly trimmed and trimmed
and trimmed our planning processes such
that at this point I pretty much only
care what we're going to do in the next
12 weeks and beyond that we might have
one target or two Targets by the end of
the year but we're not going to dedicate
a lot of resources to this and this is
somebody who's coming who who's a big
fan of preparation but I've just found
that it ended up being a huge waste of
time mostly because whenever I looked at
the plans that I made the year before
one year later I was like man half this
stuff isn't even relevant anymore
because of new changes and conditions
and so I will probably continue to lean
more in this direction and I think this
has become a little bit more popularized
by some of the CEOs like Jensen hang who
despite having Nvidia over 30 plus years
has recently talked about how he
basically doesn't do a lot of long-term
planning because fundamentally you have
things that you can do today and those
are the things you begin to allocate now
sometimes do what you need to do today
is work for something that's going to
happen in the future but you can only
control what you do today and so I have
shifted more and more in terms of what
will this change about our Behavior and
the rest of it I more or less toss out
so let me give you a couple visuals to
make this real and so the first thing is
that we think that you're going to have
this really neat line of how the growth
is going to happen right but reality is
very messy and so what's likely going to
happen is that you will Flatline and
then figure something out and then
you'll Flatline and then figure
something out and Flatline to figure
something out this is what it looks like
if you were to zoom in on this little
area here right if you were to zoom in
here it actually looks closer to what
this is which is you have the stagnation
and then you have these improvements
that occur and then increase Revenue now
one of the things that's also shifted my
perspective on how to plan is let's say
that we've got thing a thing B thing C
thing D thing e that we need to do well
before this I would try and you know
divers you know delegate each of these
things to person one person two person
three person four person five and so on
but I would say that that appears to me
like I have not done my job because I
need to do a better job prioritizing one
of these things is the most important
and if you can't decide what that is
then you are not doing your job and you
certainly can't expect your team to make
that decision for you and so I've had to
look at this and say if I could only
pick one of these things and we only
accomplish that thing
which of these would get us closer to
our vision for what the company should
be which ones would move us the furthest
forward which of these is the biggest
domino and so what I've redone is I say
Okay a is actually the priority I don't
need to order B through C here I don't
need to worry about what order these are
in and then I will take 1 + 2 + 3 + 4
plus 5 and get all of these resources
concentrated on solving a and then what
I found is that once you solve a with
all those resources because everyone's
aligned then all of a sudden B happens
faster C happens faster D happens faster
than trying to do them all at once so
let's say that you ran an agency right
so you do meta ads for small businesses
like a very typical business so if that
was your business you might say okay we
need to you know get more
leads so that means we're going to
increase ads okay that's one of the
things we're going to you know increase
show rate because our show up rate sucks
so we're going to we're going to try and
fix that we've got a hire you know a
sales manager and whatever else right
like you've got you've got you've got
your tasks I'll just put dot dot dot dot
dot dot now if this was your objective a
good strategist says given the resources
I currently have what one thing could I
do that would make all of these problems
disappear the good strategist would
would then say well if I had a brand and
I invested in my brand well would that
would that accomplish my leads thing yep
now I wouldn't have ads but it would
accomplish my problem with getting leads
now would show up rates be higher if I
have a warm audience yes would my close
rate be okay because everyone is being
warmer probably now you might have to
still hire the sales manager you can see
how the entire Dynamic would change if
only this were true and so then it
follows okay well what are the resources
required to make this happen and if I
know what those resources are and I have
those resources available then it would
follow that I should do this one thing
and then in so doing accomplish all of
these other things as a consequence and
this is why to be clear if you're like
wait well they're just going to say
build a better product because if you
have a good product you're not going to
lose people you're going to get word of
mouth you're going to have higher LTV or
they're just going to say you know Alex
is just going to say build a good brand
because if you build a good brand then
all these other problems go away no
that's called Leverage and so you're
like no no no I don't want to do the one
thing that would solve all my problems I
want to try and solve each of my
problems individually well that's
amazing for you and you should probably
get that looked at but the point is is
that a good strategist has to look at
all available options given the
resources they have and say which one of
these gets me the most and fundamentally
that is leverage next up is the
strongest force in all of business and
so I believe in this so thoroughly that
there are only two concepts that are
embedded within the acquisition. comom
logo the first is this cross here which
is the supply and demand curve that
exists in any Market the second part is
why is this a triangle the triangle is
there to exist as a full crumb for
leverage and so fundamentally if you can
have a supply demand curve that is
dramatically in your favor that alone
will dictate this if you are the only
person who sells this one thing and the
entire world wants it you going to make
a lot of money money pretty much no
matter what doesn't matter how good you
are at Market doesn't matter how good
you are at sales doesn't matter how good
you are at pricing you're going to make
a ton of money and so I try to think
what are the fewest things that have to
be true in order for me to win and I
would rather just get those things right
and then everything else can fall away
and so think about this in sequence
Supply demand is the first and most
important thing as long as we have those
things then if you had that hypothetical
example of the entire world wants
something and you're the only one who
does it what's the next thing you would
need which is Leever
you would want to be able to get as much
for the effort that you put in because
you would get bottlenecked based on
maybe your supply chain you'd have other
dependencies that would prevent you from
capitalizing on the opportunity that the
supply and demand curve has put in front
of you and so in a perfect world you
have all of that and unlimited leverage
and that allows you to maximally
capitalize on opportunities and that is
why I designed the acquisition. comom
logo to exhibit those things now the
first piece here is understanding
whether your business is Supply or
demand constrained and so a supply
constrained business for example is one
that's like cleaning like cleaners often
don't have a hard time finding other
businesses or other homes to do cleaning
for a lot of people just don't want to
do it the issue they have is finding
staff who can do the cleaning with them
or for them so that means that your
supply side of how you can deliver to
the demand is usually the issue and this
happens a lot of times with I would
consider nuisance services so services
that people might know how to do but
just don't want to do a different
example of this in the professional
setting would be like accounting firms
accounting firms a lot of people don't
want to hire accountants and for a big
period of time in a lot of companies
growth in the beginning you don't have
in-house accounting and so having an out
ofh housee accountant there's plenty of
demand for them the issue they have is
recruiting really good accountants and
so yet again they are a supply
constrained business now this works
again with legal it works with high-end
Consulting like if you're a very good
consultant in a niche it's very like
easy to get people to want to buy from
you very hard to get other people to do
what you can do because you're really
good at this thing right and so this is
very typical in a lot of businesses
especially service and so that would be
Supply constrainted businesses and if
that is the constraint then what do we
do to gain leverage over the constraint
and so this is where okay is there a way
that we can build a community of
accountants that we can then recruit
from is there a way that we can create
some sort of environment that attracts
more cleaners can our compensation
structure can we have a referral system
internally for our team or our employees
because I know what a cleaner I know
what a legal person I know what another
consultant is worth to me to my business
in total gross profit per year and why
would I not be willing to pay 20% of
that to somebody now you might do that
math and be like holy cow I make 250,000
a year per new lawyer who joins my firm
it' probably be a lot more than that
honestly in that case then why would I
be unwilling to spend $50,000 to go and
not not only that give that $50,000 to
someone on my team for bringing another
great lawyer in and so this scales all
the way up and all the way down based on
the revenue that each of these high-end
or Supply constrained employees provides
the business now those are Supply
constraint businesses and if you're in
one of those you need to recognize it
because the real businesses you're in is
attracting hiring training managing and
incentivizing these people to perform
that's the real business because the
demand kind of takes care of itself of
course you have to do the basics but the
real issue is going to be on the back
end not the front end now let's flip the
tables there are some businesses that
are demand constrainted now demand
constrainted businesses will be
typically like e-commerce businesses
often times software businesses
specifically B2B software businesses can
be demand constrained typically iCal
consumer products weight loss for
example is a very demand constrain
business now this m sounds wild to you
like wait I think so many people want to
lose weight yeah there's just even more
people who Supply it and so many
different methods for doing it now again
all of these things can shift right
supply and demand is a curve like it can
move right this is dynamic and this
video exists in time and unfortunately
the environments change but anybody
who's been in Fitness would understand
that getting customers is actually
typically the hardest part finding train
ERS not that hard there's lots of people
that like training and they'll even do
it for free same thing with musicians
like if you teach music classes right
one of the difficulties there is
attracting people who want to buy music
lessons but there's tons of people who
play music and do it for free right and
so the idea is which side of this curve
are you on and then whatever that side
is is asking yourself how can I gain
more leverage over this problem so that
I can solve it at scale once and for all
rather than having to solve it
continuously over and over and over
again so I'll give you an example I had
a a company who came out that we were
looking at and they were a little bit on
the smaller side but they were a home
services company and so the issue they
had is they were struggling to attract
plumbers and so one of the things that
we put in place for the business was
well what does a plumber bring in every
year and let's call it $400,000 in gross
profit okay so if you have a nut of
$400,000 that you know you've got the
demand for they're turning away business
cuz their phones ringing too much and
they can't even take it what are you
willing to pay one time to unlock
$400,000 every year in gross profit well
if you were to think about that like an
investment right which would be like
okay I've got this stock that yields
$400,000 in gross profit per year to me
what would I be willing to pay for it
and that's every year well shoot I'd be
at least willing to pay $400,000 if it
was a stock right that's 100% return
because next year I'm going to make
$400,000 too now there is an element of
risk that comes into the equation what
if the person leaves what if they get
fired they're not good all of those
things so those are for sure there which
means that we would then apply some sort
of discount to account for that risk but
I think that one of the big
misconceptions that business owners have
is they're not willing to pay enough for
talent that is the constraint of their
business like right now if you could get
10 more like if you were in a supply
coning business if you could get 10 more
of not not star just appropriately
competent employees who could service
the demand that you have would that
double or triple your business if so yes
what would you pay in order to double
Tri your business probably a lot more
than it costs you to attract those
people cool then what do we do well the
easiest thing is incentivize all the
people in your existing Workforce to go
do that recruiting for you too many
business owners will give like a $1,000
referral bonus on something that makes
$400,000 a year in gross profit well
that's dumb if if I can give $25,000
away or $50,000 away and I can get it
solved in a month then every month
because that $400,000 doesn't happen at
once it happens over this period of time
and so if I can actually solve the
problem two months earlier then that
means I get get to collect $35,000 for
two more months of gross profit okay so
there is a Time component of this so
maybe you can get the referral and maybe
it does take you 6 months instead of
three but you missed out on whatever
that is $105,000 in gross profit that
you could have had had you just been
willing to pay a little bit more but
still less overall and you still get to
keep that person for life so you'll
notice that I'm talking a lot about who
in these examples and you know it's one
of those big obvious TR responses that
everyone who is a senior entrepreneur or
senior investor or Warren Buffett or
Steve Jobs they all say the same thing
it's just about the people right bet on
the jockey not the horse there's tons of
isms in this world and everyone nods
along but the problem is that people
don't have the context to understand the
levels of talent that exist and this is
why these mistakes are so hard to Bear
because you have to have some sort of
pattern recognition of having worked
with one terrible people to know how to
avoid them and then secondarily what
star Talent looks like and sometimes it
takes luck in the beginning and then
over time you start recognizing what
that looks like so that you can do it on
purpose rather than on accident and if
you think about people as one of the
highest leverage things you can do so
think about this as hypothetical if your
business had people who could do
everything that currently exists and you
could simply own it that would mean that
you could work zero and make almost the
same amount that you do now you'd only
have to find someone who could do what
you do like literally just think about
what you currently make think about what
you currently do if you could pay
someone less than what you currently
make in distributions to do 100% of what
you currently do you could feasibly
retire at your current income level just
with that one Higher the idea of getting
really good people is still undervalued
in the marketplace which is why there's
always an opportunity for people who
know how to attract and retain the best
talent there's a reason that the most
expensive companies in the world in the
stock market are at War for talent I
want to say like 18 months ago one of
the headlines of I think like the New
York Times or something was the talent
War and the whole idea was just that
it's an onslaught of signing bonuses and
Kumbaya and free lunch and all this
stuff to try and attract the top talent
because they know that the leverage of
having somebody who's a 10x engineer or
a 100x marketer for their business is
always worth more than what they're
going to pay the individual and so
they're just doing everything they can
to get them and this is me trying to
translate that to you in terms of my
emphasis over the last year or years
that has yielded this outcome if we're
thinking about more or less in terms of
my focus this is one that I'm doing more
of I'm more focused on Talent I'm more
focused on better people fewer better
people and incentivizing them and
incentivizing other people to bring them
in there's some semiconductor companies
that are offering 3x salaries their
current salary to poach people from one
company to another because the cost of
switching is obviously high and so if
they're making more money than you you
should look at what they're doing so
next point up for me is of the first 100
days this year I took zero days off
and I bring this up because this is a
very taboo topic and I want to be clear
do whatever you want I'm just saying
that when I see the entrepreneurs who
were obsessed with their work they do
better than people who aren't and it's
basically that their discretionary time
that would go to hobbies that would go
to other things basically all flows into
this one thing and so I'm going to paint
a different picture for you if I played
video games all day and someone came up
to me and said hey why don't you go
outside and I say I don't want to go
outside I want to keep playing video
games the thing is is that that person's
making some moral judgment that I should
do something that they have projected
onto my life now I'm a big believer in
personal freedom which is if you want to
play video games every hour every day
until the day you die that's your
prerogative It's not how I would want to
live my life but more power to you if
you have an outcome that you're
optimizing towards which would be
Financial wealth which is kind of the
point of my channel the people who work
the most tend to make the most money and
there's a number of reasons for that so
number one is you make more money when
you work more because you have less time
to spend it that sounds obvious but I
think it's like kind of silly like if
you work you make more if you stop
working you not only don't make you also
spend so it's a it's a it's a negative
to positive swing it's actually
disproportionate the next thing is that
um a friend of mine messaged Elon about
vacations he's like hey you should you
should go on vacation or we should go
here for vacation and elon's response
was I don't do vacation
and I was like man I love this guy I
bring this up yet again because I feel
like the more you get in the game the
more addicted to the game you get and I
think that addiction is just a term that
Society uses for activities that people
do that have negative consequences
rather than simply things that you do on
a regular basis well I'm addicted to
food because I do it every day I'm
addicted to sleep because I do it every
day I'm addicted to talking to Lila
because I do it every day and so it's
just that addictions is when they decide
that the outcome of that thing is
somehow negative but if the outcome of
what I do helps more businesses grow and
is something that I enjoy why is this
wrong and so we did two very bad
vacations this year one was in July 4th
which I ended up basically just
traveling and then working the whole
time so I don't know if I would consider
that a vacation and then the other one
we went to truly do a vacation and so
this one was going to be 2 days and we
got there and it was this beautiful
luxury resort and there's only 22 Villas
it's like three or four people per Villa
like very you know ritzy whatever and I
look out on the patio of the Villa that
we have over the mountains and I'm like
man this is beautiful and I don't care
and I think it was this realization that
even vacations were something that had
been passed on to me from someone
earlier in my life that I was something
that I should do that I must do this or
else I will not gain their approval and
I will get judgment from people that I
care about but when I think about who do
I care about who would care about
whether or not I go on vacation there
very very few and they certainly don't
have the things that I want or have
accomplished what I would like to
accomplish and so why would I listen to
them the big conclusion that I've had
from this whole thing was maybe
vacations aren't for me or maybe they're
not for me right now and that's totally
okay who made the rule that vacations
must exist humans existed for a very
long time before vacations were a thing
and so the idea that this is a
requirement for humans is very foreign
and feels societally programmed also
takes into the assumption that you have
the money for the vacations it's
basically a privileged thing that you
then cast a projection onto somebody
else saying they should exercise this
privilege because that's what you would
do in their position but maybe the
reason you would do it in their position
is why you're not in their position and
so one of the other things that we did
this year is that we traveled
significantly less and so this year in
total I think we took somewhere in the
neighborhood 12 you know 10 to 12 days
off in total and I would Define a day
off as not working at all that would be
a day off and so I would say workday I
would Define as more than C four hours
of work as a work day so maybe on the
days off I would still consider I worked
for a few hours but I'll count that as a
day off so big picture The increased
focus and decrease in change in
variables in my environment allowed me
to work more because I had fewer
changing variables that I had to
accommodate on a regular basis and so
Lela and I were looking over our
calendars yesterday we did a joint
podcast going over each month of the
year like what we focused on in that
month and what was interesting is that
we kept swiping through it it was just
just like work work work just like an
onslaught of things that we did over and
over and over again and I can tell you
this is that the periods where I've had
tremendous Financial growth across
different companies that I founded have
almost always had these very long
periods where I just have to do reps and
this is like I'm in a rocky cut scene of
my own right now and I know that it's
likely going to take three-ish years and
I'm probably about a year in and I
probably have two more years to get to
the other side and it's just that I've
been on this roller coaster before and I
know how the song goes it's less like
weird for me and also I don't have the
anxiety of will this be forever I know
it's not going to be forever and I know
that it's a season and even if it is
forever I have found that it's far more
productive for me to work seven days a
week 8 to 10 hours a day than it is for
me to work five and take two people have
different preferences but for me it's
kind of like the summer Gap in learning
so when kids take 3 months off for the
summer they have this whole summer
catchup that they have to do which takes
like another quarter for them to just
get back to where they were and so if
you think about the 3 months plus the
katchup it's like kids are only like net
positive for like 6 months of the year
and the other 6 months they're not so
they're basically learning at half speed
from an entrepreneur perspective we're
incentivized to get as much quality work
done as possible and so for me I work
very well on realistically a 10 to 12
hour a day schedule obviously there's
probably two or 3 days a week that I'll
work 16 to 18 but I would say my my true
average is probably 7 days a week of 12
and i' would say weekends are shorter
and I probably have two or three days
like I said during the week that are
probably 18s and so that gets me
somewhere in the 90 hours a week range
but for me that's actually fairly doable
because my wife's here with me I have a
gym downstairs I have all the people
that I care about and I I care about
them because they support me they take
interest in my goals and they want to
help me accomplish them they increase
the likelihood that those goals occur
and so what else could I ask from
someone for my life like what I'm I'm
very happy with my life and I think that
a lot of people take offense to me being
happy about my life because they think
that I cast judgment on them living
differently you can do whatever you want
I make this channel because I've been
trying to document this since I had
nothing all the way to a billion dollars
plus and just say what's worked for me
my team asked me to clarify this because
they're with me a 100 days straight
means no weekends so I just worked the
first 100 days of the year so that took
me into whatever that is April so a lot
of you hear 100 days and think oh my God
my friends would throw a fit if I worked
100 days straight
well if you want better friends then
expect to see them less because better
friends are busy friends better friends
are doing things with their lives and I
don't know about you but I would rather
see someone less frequently who's
actually pursuing great things than
someone who's always available to see me
all the time and has zero material
updates because they are in no way
growing or getting better because my
biggest fear would that they rub off on
me and the friends that I have now I can
count on one hand and almost all of them
are entrepreneur I say almost they're
all entrepreneurs and they're all very
high level entrepreneurs and we
basically stay in touch via text and
none of them live in the same state as
me all of my friends treat text like
email which is like we text and none of
us have an expectation of response it's
like oh I can't believe you didn't
respond to my text for three days it is
super normal for each of my friends to
have not responded to me and for me not
to respond to them for days at a time
and none of us blow up and have a
tantrum
because we know the other person's busy
and they'll get to it when they get to
it so with on on the on the on the back
end of that uh serious note fun things
did happen this year and so I ended up
buying aq.com three-letter domain from
Yahoo and so they had owned that since
1998 or9 I can't remember it was 90 it
was 96 through 98 so they had owned it
for like 26 years something like that
and I finally was able to wrestle it
from there from their grip and so that
was really cool for those of you curious
it was $480,000 to buy the domain I
don't buy a lot of crazy and um I'm
allowed to spend my money however I want
to spend it and I think aq.com is dope
and so on the back end of that part of
the reason I did that was because we
just uh stood up acq Ventures so really
proud of that it's primarily focused on
uh SAS and Tech enabled Services the
reason that we're doing it is basically
because our family office which
functions like a private Equity but it's
a family office in that we don't have uh
outside LPS or limited partners people
who give us money so we don't have any
people give us money it's all our money
which is why it's a family office but in
terms of the day-to-day most family
offices tend to be passive we are very
active in our investments and we take
significantly larger positions and so we
stood this up because we have a
tremendous amount of people who who uh
who are entrepreneurs we meet uh through
the various things that we do that would
like uh investment they would like help
but they don't want to necessarily hand
over control or hand over have that
level of Engagement and so we we stood
up acq Ventures because there's just
honestly a ton of demand for a different
capital structure uh for our investments
we just did our first three Deals in acq
Ventures I think should finalize in the
next week or two so before the end of
the year kind of cool and so that will
be a much higher volume deal side for
acquisition. comom and that Branch will
just be on the Venture side well
speaking of big things that I did this
year I worked a crazy amount on the $100
million scaling road map and it's yours
for free and I'll tell you how to get it
right now I did it across all eight
departments so the departments were
sales marketing customer service product
it HR recruiting and finance and so what
problem exists at every level and I
broke it into 10 stages and what you
need to do to graduate from that level
so you can literally just look at your
own business and see what things you're
missing what things you're lagging on
maybe sometimes what things you're ahead
on because it's very neat to put these
things into 10 stages but reality is
messy and so it's more that you'll be at
stage five you'll have some things that
you're at stage seven on and some things
that you're at stage three on but those
stage three things will likely be things
that you will need to fix sooner than
the things that you're at stage seven on
right and so it's very much the
constraints concept where you have a
weak link and this helps you see where
you're the furthest behind so you can
kind of uplevel those things faster and
so I just dropped the training it's at
acquisition. comom trining and so if you
want to write down the link this is it
it's acquisition. comom trining and just
click the $100 million scaling roadmap
and you can go there we also have a
little button there that you can get a
personalized plan made for you so you
just answer some questions and we'll
tell you what stage uh you are at and
we'll give you the one before and the
one after so you know what you should be
finished and what you have a line of
sight to uh it's absolutely free uh you
can just go there and uh enjoy it's 14
hours you don't need to watch the whole
thing just watch the section that's
that's specific to your business right
now so big thing right now is growth
Trends so I think this might be one of
the most valuable sections uh of this
video for you guys and historically when
I would do my podcast recap of the year
was always my most popular episode and
so now I'm just doing it on YouTube but
these were the things that I would say
we learned or that we doubled down on in
the portfolio that yielded really good
results so number one is we focused a
lot on leadership Talent recruiting all
right so you call this key player
recruiting um and the big thing here is
that I kind of switched my perspective
on this which is fundamentally if you
listen to Steve Jobs you listen to Bezos
you listen to Zuckerberg a lot of them
take a a hugely active role in bringing
in top talent and so my understanding of
talent has been probably the single
largest shift that I've had this year in
terms of my understanding of business
and why I think that we're
disproportionately growing across the
portfolio the companies that are doing
the best are the ones that we've been
able to to place key players and part of
that is being willing as the CEO as the
founder to actively show interest in
these types of people and they are the
type of people that would not respond to
traditional recruiter because they are
either so good at what they do and they
want to know that their investment in
the compan is going to be valuable these
are not the type of people who feel
you're giving them an opportunity to
work for you these are the types of
people that they are giving you the
opportunity of helping build your
business bringing their entire Rolodex
of people they already know teams that
sometimes they can they can bring with
them and just a huge stack of skills
that ideally should disproportionately
benefit the business and fundamentally
this is one of the highest leverage
things that you can do because at the
most basic level what you need to do as
a CEO is attract the absolute best
people and align incentives ruthlessly
for them to work and then get out of
their way and so that was probably the
the one of the biggest ones number two
was was Focus all right now I talk about
focus a lot so I'm I'm going to try and
say this in a different way than I
normally do it's really top down focus
and prioritization which is just another
word for strategy but just how much more
important strategy is for businesses
because what happens is when they pursue
too many paths they get they look up a
year later and they haven't grown much
at all and if if you're a small business
like you absolutely can double triple
quadruple 5x every year for a few years
before sometimes that'll slow down now
if you have a compounding mechanism it
could even keep going and getting faster
at the very least like growing at 10% a
year again there's nothing wrong with
that but if you're at a million bucks a
year or five million bucks a year even
$10 million a year like you should be
able to grow a lot faster than that and
typically it's because you lack people
and because you lack focus and when I
say people it means you lack good enough
people the people you have you might
have a a high headcount but a low Talent
account and focus you might have lots of
priorities but they're the wrong ones
and so fundamentally if you can't focus
on one thing one objective that is most
important that makes the rest of your
objectives less important then you are
not doing your job as the CEO to tell
the team how they should be allocating
their attention and that and here's the
important part is
deleting everything that is not this and
so a lot of people are like these are
our objectives also keep doing
everything else it's like you can't do
that you can't just add more because now
you you've even further diluted what's
important now for sure people need to
continue transact sales guys still need
to sell customer service still needs to
service but the discretionary effort
that exists in the top talent the
leaders of the company who aren't as
involved in the day-to-day and are
basically all times they have between
aligning teams should be dedicated to a
single priority that if accomplished
would be an order of magnitude
Improvement in the business and so this
level of focus is what I continue to
drill with the founders and the CEOs of
the portfolio companies and it has
yielded outsize returns and there's a
great razor for this which is when I
want to fix a system or when I go into a
department the first thing I do is
eliminate as much as humanly possible
and here's the thing is people are
afraid of eliminating meetings
eliminating communication lines
eliminating processes but if you
eliminate just about everything you'll
find out that the vast majority of that
stuff was complete waste and complete
distraction and here's the cool thing
you can always add it back so there's
this sphere of loss people literally
have fear of loss around processes and
meetings which is ridiculous but that's
just how we're wired psychologically
which is why companies in general as
they grow create bloat there's too many
people doing too many things that don't
matter or not enough stuff to begin with
and all of them together don't know how
what they do makes the company money and
so one of the easiest tasks that you can
do is zoom all the way out and think
what is the output of this department
what is the output of Finance have you
ever thought about like what is the
output of Finance the output of Finance
is information to make decisions that's
it and so if you're getting too much
information or you're getting the wrong
information or the information that
you're getting doesn't change your
decisions then the function of Finance
is inadequate you're not getting enough
of what you need of output from that
department if the function of it is to
gather store display and analyze
information then are you getting the
correct data are you able to analyze it
are you able to display it and see in
real time um and be able to make
decisions off it also another
information output Department kind of
interesting right so many of these
departments really exist just to have
information to make decisions and so I
bring this up because you have to delete
until you have the fewest things that
matter it's like you want to cut to the
Bone you don't want to cut to fat or cup
muscle you want to go all the way to the
Bone and then add the few things that
matter most back in and I think that I'm
doing this better now because honestly I
think I'm just more ruthless and I think
I care less about judgments of other
people I think I'm honestly I think it's
just like I'm more confident what I'm
doing now and so it's like I think I
conceptually felt the same way I just
was like this feels crazy even though it
makes sense to me and so fundamentally
first principles thinking operates from
this perspective of like okay physics
are laws that we have to obey what else
do we have to obey the law of the land
so we've got government laws that we
have to obey besides that tell me a
physical law or government law that
prevents us from doing this thing in one
tenth of the time tell me the law if not
then there is a way and here's the thing
is that there will simply be resources
that are required and so one of the
things that I'm trying to get my team to
understand is if I ask to do something
and they say we can't do it that's
saying it's impossible and it's
ridiculous and of course they're wrong
so it's a terrible position to take it's
also very frustrating instead tell me
what it would take tell me the resources
that would be required that we'd have to
take from something else and then we
together can decide whether it's worth
the trade so for example if my whole
media team I said hey I want to make AEM
motion picture for example right I'm not
saying I want to do that let's say that
we decided that was a big a big
strategic party if we were to get one
big motion picture that was as big as
Avatar uh then it would be you know
maybe it would do things for the
business okay then they might say well
we can't do that now implicit in that
statement is we can't do that and keep
making content at the at the level that
we're at so then we'd say okay well if
we allocated all the resources and stop
making content and we actually were able
to get a featurelength film with the
existing media team would the benefit of
that be worth the the cost and if it is
then great we'll do it but a lot of
times we get a we get a soft no
immediately out the gate rather than a
what it would take and this has been one
of the biggest shifts that I think has
empowered me is asking better questions
and so one of the most frequently asked
questions that I will probably my
question of the year is what would it
take and by doing this the reason I
think it's such a powerful question it
also works for deals it works for sales
it works for anything is that it assumes
the result occurs it assumes success and
so because it assumes success you work
backwards from the reality that you want
to create rather than forwards trying to
figure it out as you go I'll tell you
something funny so we had a company that
we were looking at and um in the
diligence process I said hey you've got
this downsell basically no one takes it
have you considered just giving it away
for free to get more leads and they
ended up doing it and they tripled their
lead flow the next
week and so that downsell was worth
maybe 5% of Revenue but what's the value
of tripling lead flow tripling revenue
and probably disproportionately dropping
to the bottom line so tripling really
would triple lead flow so it would cut
CAC by 2/3 but fundamentally it would it
would triple the business and so there
are so many of these little things that
exist inside of companies and just being
focused enough to say no this is our
core product this is where we make all
of our money anything that's not that
distracts us from making this thing
better so theme number three was cro and
so I'd say this year the companies that
made the biggest gains uh had a
discipline around conversion rate
optimization and so that means that at
any given point they're running three to
10 different split tests on the key
parts of the pipeline for Revenue
generation meaning if you have a landing
page where you get a lot of traffic or
you have a homepage that you get a lot
of traffic or you have a follow-up
sequence that a huge percentage of your
customers are in actually testing things
out there so one of the companies we had
had three cro improvements and this was
the largest company we have in the
portfolio so we got A plus 20% cro test
Improvement which is a mass a monster
win especially at the level of
optimization that this company's in so
we're talking eight figures plus a month
in Revenue like it's a big company and
So 20% lift is huge but on top of that
we got a 50% lift and then we got a 28%
lift so we had three Mega wins now the
question is how many split tests did we
have to do for that I mean probably 100
but the thing is is that that was
basically one guy and a couple devs
split basically running these sprints on
a regular basis but how valuable is that
to the company tremendously valuable
because things that are efficiency uh
improvements typically are long lasting
what's cool about that is that when you
have an efficiency Improvement it means
your LTV to CAC ratio expands which
allows you to spend more money in
advertising more money in Talent
acquisition all the way around the
business it literally just makes the
business stronger and is a competitive
mode and so I'll give you a little hack
that is worth looking at which is many
businesses integrate thirdparty tools
into your processes right you've got a
100 different softwares that you
probably pay for what none of those
softwares typically advertise is what
their conversion rate is and so if
anything is customer facing that a
prospect might interact with I would
look at three or four other tools within
the exact same use case and see which
one has a higher conversion rate on the
ux so the user experience I think you
will get
disproportionate Returns on that it's
typically a heavier lift because
splitting between multiple tools is a
pain in the ass but I've seen monster
lifts there so those are the three
probably biggest themes which was people
focus and then optimization around the
things that worked really well across
the portfolio uh in 2025 now the next
part is okay well what are the
detractors right these are the things
that grew those businesses but what are
some of the things that hurt those
businesses and so I actually see this as
the personal stuff all right so we had a
few entrepreneurs that I think took
their foot off the gas they started
making more money than they'v been
accustomed to and we like this is good
enough and so this is where having you
know some people call it a big reason
why you can have whatever you want as
long as you change your behavior I don't
really care what it's a big reason why
or you just change but either way you
have to find something that's going to
keep driving you so for me it's the Love
of the Game I just enjoy business and so
I spend all my time doing business some
people don't enjoy business as much and
so it either has to be some mission that
you have around the problem that you
solve like it actually has to light you
up otherwise you will make enough money
and you'll stop pushing then now again
if you accomplish your goals that's
amazing that's great again I make my
channel for people who just want to
consistently grow consistently grow in
personal development and using money is
just a stick for seeing how how far how
far You' you've stacked your skills
right also not saying that money is a a
is a virtue or having money is a virtue
just saying that in general you step you
become more skilled and you can measure
how skilled you are in the game of
Business by the amount of money you make
now here's one that's going to be
uncomfortable for a lot of people is
spouses indoor partners and so one of
the big detractors believe it or not and
I've seen this and this is a big Focus
that Laya and I have across the team is
how much support do the key players on
your team and or the entrepreneurs have
from their spouses and so you basically
have the worst type of spouse which is a
spouse who actively decreases the likel
to your goals so they are constantly
reminding you of the negatives that
exist they're trying to constantly
distract you say hey stop working stop
talking about that let's do this instead
so not only do they try to get you to
stop working they try incentivize You by
doing something else and so it's
reversing a negative and a positive it's
like a double whimmy and the thing is is
that I want to be clear I don't think
there's malicious intention here but the
result of what they do still massively
damages the business like if you were to
think of an enemy what would an enemy do
they would try and get you to not think
about the business and then do something
else that you get addicted to instead
it's almost like going to the to your
competitor and be like try some heroin I
think you might like it what occurs is
more or less the same and again I'm not
talking about intention here I'm just
talking about what happens and so when
we looked back so we did like a
retroactive analysis of this of like who
were the stars who just crushed and kept
growing they were the ones who had
absolute spouse support who were like if
they need to work late they need to work
the weekends I'll pack them with a lunch
I'm you know I'm here at home and this
happened for husbands and wives both
sides the ones who where you had
somebody who came in who presented like
a star but then eventually fizzled was
typically because and this is where it's
so nefarious is that they would get into
a relationship ship at some point or
they they would upgrade the relationship
like they'd move in together right
something like that and that person
would have a disproportionate effect on
the entrepreneur and so what's really
interesting is that entrepreneurs are
typically we're so concerned with our
surroundings who we want in our space
who's who's good who's helping us out
and then for some reason the person who
has a 71 correlation with your
subjective well-being the person who
will probably have the largest influence
on your behavior in your life you don't
hold to the same standard and I find
that crazy but it happens all the time
and just just because everyone else does
it doesn't mean that it makes sense it's
also why most people are mediocre I
think that one is that if you're looking
to bring a highle person onto the team I
would consider talking to their spouse
just make just gauge their interest
level see if they're supportive like in
the middle they're neutral but I think
neutral becomes negative over time so
you need someone who's active who's
who's who when when the employee
inevitably has a bad day because
everyone does they say hey this is a
great job this is great for us as a
family like you got this I trust you I
believe in you I support you what can I
do to help tell me how I can make this
easier for you that is the type of
support you want whereas if you have
somebody who says let's leave work
outside it's home now and I I don't want
to hear about that let's do all this
other stuff instead that sounds innocent
the problem is that it decreases the
likelihood they win and again I know
this will be controversial so you know
take it or leave it again my two cense
you can tell me to shove it it's up to
you let's talk about the next big one so
uh in creating that scaling road map
that I was talking about earlier I
wanted to create like a micro cycle that
I felt had to exist within every process
right and so I'm going to break down two
different processes that are different
one is scaling the other is optimization
all right so I'm going to walk through
both so whenever you have a system
you'll typically start as the first step
so whatever you're doing you want to
start out you have to start Number One S
then you have C which is compound all
right so you have to do more okay great
we're doing more the next is augment so
so how do we do
better then we have leverage which is
how do we make it consistent right how
do we automate it and so I'll just I'll
I'll make this a little infinite thing
and then finally how do we expand again
and so this is actually a
loop between each of these steps so you
start and then you do more and then once
you do more you try to get better once
you get better and you know what works
you try and automate it and make it
consistent and have low volatility and
then you expand to the next territory
you expand to the next Channel you
expand to the next type of content you
expand to the next product the same
process and it's nice because it has
this little uh it's got this nice
acronym s c a l e and so it actually fit
in there um I was super pumped about
that and so now when I think about what
someone has to do next within an
apartment I have think okay where are
they at okay they just started this
thing so they just need to do more oh
they've done a lot okay so maybe there's
probably a lot of wayte so now we
probably should do better how can we
augment how can we streamline how can we
optimize once they're doing better it's
like okay they're doing really well but
there's more demand that's coming in how
can we make this consistent how can we
automate this or portions of this work
and then finally once we have this thing
airtight we're like cool how can we do
this again and we expand if we're
thinking about this within the context
of content it's like we start posting on
a channel then we say okay well one post
a day works can we do three posts a day
so we do more then we're like hey some
of these posts do better than others how
can we make our post better and then we
say cool what percentage of these
processes can we use AI for what things
can we pre-prep we can B basically make
better happen more easily and more
consistently how can we make it instead
of having you know one do 10K views and
one have a million views how can we get
all of them over 100k how can we get all
of them over 250k and then finally we're
like okay I think we've maxed out this
specific Channel how do we now go to Tik
Tok how do we take this process and go
to Snapchat or whatever so it works for
anything now the second process so
that's about scaling this is about
optimization and so this is typically
when you come in and fix something that
already exists and so I got to have a
lot of experience with this this year
because I took over media and conversion
within acquisition. comom and I haven't
operated day-to-day probably in like 5
years and so it was actually a ton of
fun for me because honestly it's just
like I've I've developed a lot of skills
since the last time I operated and uh
it's been great so anyways the first
thing is you question the requirements
and I got this framework from Elon and
it's freaking awesome so question the
requirements why are we doing everything
that we're doing please explain to me
how does this thing relate to this
output and this is why defining what
each Department is supposed to create is
so valuable you're the content team the
goal here is to make as much good
content as humanely possible anything
that does not facilitate content
Creation in terms of volume and quality
is waste if you're an engineering team
it's like you have code that you must
type which then creates software that
people can use and we want the quality
of that software to be really high and
so anything that does not relate to
those things are things that are waste
so we question why we do everything the
second once you kind of get lay of the
land after questioning is you delete and
you delete because the next few steps
are going to be adding resources to the
system and so you delete everything that
doesn't matter so the first step that I
did when I took over the media team was
I deleted all meetings now to be clear
it doesn't mean that we're never going
to have meetings again it just means
that I will find out which meetings
matter and then we will add those in
proportionally and so I said you can
have ad hoc discussions about clear
things but otherwise I'm canceling the
recurring meetings and I replaced all
team meetings all one-on ones with just
a daily huddle that way basically the
entire day and these were also deep
workers so everyone who's creating
content really just wants to get into
flow and anything that prevents flow
massively impacts their performance and
so it's like the solution of just adding
more people and adding more meetings
just gets more people to not work it's
terrible and most people also hate it
most people want to work and so once you
delete then you optimize which is saying
okay what of the things that we're doing
right now get us the most results what
is what are these things that get us the
least results what are the resourcers
required to do them as in like time
spent or money spent in order to get it
and then we optimize it so we say the
things that give us the most for the
least we put as the first priority the
next thing that gets us you know the
most for the most we put as the second
priority the things that get us a very
little amount that cost a lot we put at
the end and we're just basically going
to not do those things and so you
reoptimize the actual processes once
you've deleted everything else then you
pull up timelines you say how can we
make this happen faster how can we do
this in one/ tenth a time and what's
crazy is that you honestly can increase
the speed of things by 5x 10x it happens
it really it's it's mindblowing when you
do it CU you're like I can't believe how
much waste we've had this whole time all
you do is when you ask questions you say
how many hours do does that take and so
then someone's going to respond with how
many hours it take so rather than this
is the classic instead of doing end of
week deadlines you just make it end of
day and so if a team is used to
delivering something to a team meeting
every Monday and you say cool how many
hours does that take great let's have it
done by the end of the day you 7x the
speed of that team 7x and so some people
can't comprehend how one company can
grow at so much faster rate than others
and it's because of this resource
allocation they pull up time good
drivers make things happen faster
because companies's like if you
accomplish a goal in 100 years who cares
time is a huge function in business if
you don't have a process around pulling
up timelines consistently and here's why
it's so important because if you have
time today like let's say there's more
utilization on the team like you can
they have bandwidth and you pull stuff
up and they're like hey we don't need
that for another week like why are you
why are you making me do it by the end
of today because we don't know what's
going to happen next week and we might
have a priority next week that we do
need to get end of day and then when
that happens we still won't have done
this other thing and now we have to do
the other one so this other thing's now
two weeks
and so basically you want to use up all
available resources that are renewable
on a consistent basis to get the highest
return so I want to make sure like you
understand the argument there because
you're going to have to tell it to your
team the reason I'm going to drive this
outcome even though there's no apparent
outside urgency is because it assumes
that the future is going to be exactly
like today and one of the things I can
guarantee is that the future won't be
and that there will be things that you
didn't expect and when that day comes
you will want to have all of the things
that you've accomplished behind you
supporting you and have as many
resources as seemly possible available
to you to deploy in that moment because
the most adaptable player in the system
survives that is what survival of the
fittest means within the context of
business it's the most adaptable player
the most flexible and so the final step
here is automate same as before and so
this is what you look at when you're
trying to fix something or turn
something around or make it better all
right this is when you're trying to
scale something I I could probably come
up with something cute around optimized
but I many letters all right and so
hopefully those two Frameworks give you
two different ways to look at
departments when you come in you're like
okay is this a scale thing so we need to
do more we need to do better we need to
make it reliable or automated portion of
it or do we need to expand or is this
everything screwed up why are we doing
what we're doing okay delete all that
stuff optimize the things that get us
the most outcome pull up time
requirements then automate having these
types of Frameworks to solve problems
makes life so much easier which is why I
share it with you so the next one is
about success and failure and knowing
why so Professor bergerman from Stanford
has this this uh statement where he says
it's better to fail and know why you
failed than to succeed and not now
notwithstanding the outcome itself but
he's talking about you as an individual
it's better to know why you want why you
lost than not know why you won because
you can't learn anything from it
essentially it means that the success
was purely chance right which means you
can't repeat it and so Edison you know
had 10,000 ways not to know how to make
a light bulb right it's same kind of
idea and like if as long as you learn
from your failures on a long enough time
Horizon and you don't give up you will
win period And so an expert you can
Define as somebody who's made all the
mistakes that you can possibly make in a
very narrow field and so fundamentally
that's what we want want to be within
our businesses and So within that
context I have now spoken to a lot of
business owners because we started this
Workshop division so we could meet more
businesses so we could do acq Ventures
and obviously within the main portfolio
and that you're noticing I'm lining up a
lot of sheets here so there are what I
call the six Horsemen of of business
stagnation and so if you are stuck this
is for you so there are six reasons that
I've seen that have been continuous rock
and hard plac scenars and the reason
that business owners get stuck here is
because you have to choose between two
apparently impossible choices one is
pain today the other is pain forever and
both of them sting and that's why people
just Wade water in pain because hurts a
little bit less to keep pain forever
than have a lot of short-term pain now
so these are the big six so number one
is being underpriced this is how it
presents a business owner is at close to
full capacity so like let's say they
they provide some services and they're
like I can't I can't work any more than
I already have or my team can't work
anymore than it already is and and and
this is the key point and we're not
making money so when that occurs they
want to look at all these different
things but the problem is you're just
mispriced now there's the fear that if I
raise my price I will lose my customers
and then it will get worse right but the
thing is is that I have I have I have
shephered so many businesses through
price raises that it makes me sick and
the process of raising price works like
this you get to the price and then you
say a higher number and you keep going
up until people stop buying that is how
you do it in the back of knacken redneck
logic way that I prefer most times if
you're in that situation you get to pick
do you want to have a few people say no
and you make more money or do you want
to be barely above water and not be able
to expand forever because the reason you
can't expand the business is because you
don't have cash flow you don't have cash
flow because your prices are wrong and
so we need to fix the price once we fix
the price we'll free up cash with the
freed up cash we can expand a new
location
we can hire that key person that you
need to bring in number one if you are
full capacity and you aren't making
money you need to raise your price an
easy way to do it is every five plus 20
all right so I actually got this from
lifting weights it's the reverse of this
which is once you increase volume by 20%
bump your intensity up by five meaning
add five pounds right or 5% right so
bump volume by 20 bump intensity by five
and then volume will drop again but now
you have higher intensity and so it's
this kind of B balanced progression
process it's just a very simple one but
it actually works the same way for price
and so it's like you sell five customers
if they all say yes to that price or
around the same percentage or you net
more money overall you bump the price by
20% and do it again and you just keep
doing the five five and 20 keep doing 5
and 20 until eventually not enough
people are saying yes that you're
netting less money now the problem is if
you have small sales numbers it's harder
to hear no more often because your brain
isn't going to calculate the fact that
you made 20% more it's going to be
binary in its thinking of like it was a
yes or a no and the thing is is that if
you sell three people at twice the price
it's better than selling five people at
half the price but you're going to hear
no more often and so it's going to hurt
more but it is better for the business
for two reasons one you actually make
more money secondly and this is the big
one people forget you also have fewer
people to service so you have less cost
and more Revenue which those two things
together create a disproportionate
increase in profit big thing number one
fix your price
so the second big problem is
overcompensation now what I mean by this
is actually paying people not like
you're overcompensating for stuff okay
this typically happens when you have uh
a set of employees especially in service
businesses where you accidentally in the
beginning give some sort of Revenue
share or something like that so it
doesn't matter you can't out earn it
right like if you grow the business they
just grow their revenue like you you you
overcompensate them or you mcomp them
and maybe you did that in the beginning
because the revenue was really low and
you never thought you get to where
you're at now and then your big fear
right each one of these has a rock and
hard play scenario the big fear is if I
tell them that they're going that I have
to change the compensation they're going
to leave and the answer is maybe but if
you don't you'll never grow so what are
you going to do right you have to over
you have to go through the short-term
pain to get the long-term gain and so
the process that I'd recommend doing
number one is you Shore up the
infrastructure which means that you
bring someone else in that can do the
same thing as that person and do it at
the new price that you want to pay them
for then you can have the conversation
with them with more leverage and saying
hey the market is this I'm paying you
this I understand this is what I need to
pay you in order for us to accomplish
our goals which is what I sold you on is
that we want to accomplish this big
Vision with the business now I
understand that isn't like I'm changing
expectations and so go home talk to your
wife sleep on it and come back tomorrow
if you want to stay here for that
compensation I'll give you a delay so
this is the key part is you say hey I'll
keep paying you this for the next 2
months or 3 months whatever and after
that then you'll go to this new kind of
comp compens ation philosophy now if
they come back and say no I feel
underappreciated blah blah blah then
that's fine and the good news is you
already have somebody who's right there
ready to go that's the second big issue
the third big problem and this is a big
one is this is really common when you're
smaller so I'd say sub three million
this is you guys all right serve too
many I'll just say infinite avatars all
right meaning you serve too many
customers and what happens is all these
different people have different demands
and so they are telling you all these
different things and you can't get your
offer right you can't get your
advertising right because you're serving
too many people now again what's the
Rock and hardplay scenario well if I get
narrower on my avatar I'm going to sell
fewer customers and I'm getting all
these other people well to me number one
is if you fix your messaging you will
attract more of the right people but you
haven't been willing to take that bet
the alternative is you can try and be
every everything to everyone which you
know isn't going to work because it's
what you're already doing and you know
it's not working and so you have the
evidence that your your existing path is
going to stagnate you and so again Again
The Impossible choice is do you want to
keep stagnating forever and maybe you
make some money now but it's preventing
you from growing or are you willing to
and the business is about risk like you
have to be comfortable with risk like
this is going to all of these are risks
but the alternative is you never risk
and you stay exactly where you are and
so for me that is a much greater risk
it's like when you get into investing
anything you invest money into can go
down so you incur that risk but if you
never invest you absolutely will never
get wealthy so what are you going to do
right you have to take the small risk so
that you avoid the much larger long-term
risk and each of these is small
short-term risk to avoid large long-term
risk so here you have to Niche down who
you're serving which you do by 8020 so
that means you look at all of your
customers and you say what are the top
20% who are these people what do they do
where are they from and you say how do I
make this my message and how do I make
an offer that's only for them that they
would go nuts for and here's the part
people miss and price it accordingly so
if you have customer
that you provide five times the value to
and I'm sure you do have those people
well all of a sudden if you were to turn
some of these bad ones away then your
price could reflect the value that you
serve to only that much narrower Avatar
and that's okay and that's great so you
may yet again and by the way this is the
point make more money all of these are
counterintuitive which is why people get
stuck the next one the next Rock and
hardplay scenarios is overextension all
right so this one is you know Alex's
Alex's favorite this is Alex's greatest
hits of mistakes is me trying to take on
too many things I have a plate that's
this big and I try and I start putting
food on the table because I can't fit it
on the plate and typically this is where
you get ahead of your skis where you
open that second location when the first
location isn't really operating as much
as well as you think it is and as soon
as you go there the revenue from the
first one drops and you're like uhoh but
a lot of that was my profit and so now
you've got these fixed costs the
revenue's down and then you've got this
one but this one's new so it's not doing
as well as the first one was was and
your star person's there but you're not
there and so now you're splitting
between two locations and you're like oh
man now I'm actually making the same
amount as I was with one but now I have
two twice the risk and you're like oh
you know what the solution should be
I'll open a third and then between the
three now your profit goes down even
more and now you're not making any money
but you have three locations and you
have TR three times the risk and you're
stressed out of your mind so what do you
do honestly you have two solutions you
either have to hire incredibly
impressive people which means that
you're going to probably give up your
income in order to bring this person on
or you have to your losses you have to
prune the tree you have to reconcentrate
get it right and then scale back out
again the right way and so overextension
is typically a who problem which is you
don't have enough good people that you
left behind who can actually run it
without you and so this happens a lot of
times in like the1 to3 million range it
happens at all ranges but a lot there
because when you get there you typically
suck yourself out of the day today
you're not you're not you're not
actually selling people you're not doing
customer service and you're not doing
delivery but the issue is you think that
because you're not involved in the
acquisition and delivery that you're not
required to run the business but the
thing is is that you work every hour of
the day right now and so if you work
every hour of the day but you're not
selling and you're not delivering then
it means you're doing other stuff and
that other stuff you're doing is very
much operating the business and so a lot
of owners will mistakenly think that CEO
and owner mean the same thing you happen
to be both but they are not the same and
so right now is you leave so it's like
the CEO leaves the business and all of a
sudden the business stops running as
well because the CEO is gone so you have
to have somebody who's going to operate
behind you you have to basically
backfill yourself and in my opinion I
like a six-month test at the very least
do a one-month test which is go away for
a month and you hand your phone you show
your phone to your operator and you say
hey here's the deal you're going to get
this override on the business so a
little profit share whatever or some
stock and in doing that I'm doing this
in exchange for this not ringing that's
the deal and if this rings then that's
not the deal and so it's like then you
roll play it out so it's like let's say
a pipe burst what do you do if it's call
you wrong answer CU what do you think
I'm going to do I'm going to call a
plumber so what are you going to do just
call the plumber directly you don't need
to call me to call the plumber same idea
if it's an emergency call 911 if it's
not an emergency don't call me either
way don't call me and so this is the
trade so if you're overextended you
either got to dip into your own paycheck
to bring someone in or you got to prune
the tree reconcentrate and then build it
back right and the six-month test I was
alluding to is the business has to
either maintain or grow for six straight
months without your direct involvement
now that last point is the big one
without your direct involvement now some
of you are going to run that test still
continue to work in the day-to-day for
six months and then say oh I think I did
it but you just didn't change what you
did at all and the business continue to
operate with you as CEO which is not the
case so you just delay six months and
then you open the next location well
which should still make you a little bit
better in terms of your cash position
but not my recommendation so what's
what's what's number five so number five
is more than one business so this is
also an Alex special I have a lot of
specials here four and five are are my
my personal favorites uh that I've made
the most often which is you've got two
businesses or you've got three
businesses because you don't know how to
pick and you operate from the fallacy
that Zucker bird had a side hustle
Zuckerberg was also flipping airbnbs and
doing wholesaling on the side right and
that's how you build Facebook of course
not one of these businesses is the
business you should be doing and the
thing is is that the opportunity is the
problems that you need to solve and
aren't it's not in the
missed opportunities it's the problems
that need to be solved right it's the
hairy work that you're not sure what the
answer is but you know you need to fix
it that is where the opportunity is
because fundamentally If the product
were exceptional and everybody loved it
you wouldn't have an issue you'd be
going all in on that business and so if
that's the case then just do it now
you're going to have this sunk cost valy
of like I already put all this money
into this and I already already got it
going I already have a partner there yes
short-term risk you lose relationship
you lose maybe short-term income from
that from that business long-term risk
you never grow any of these things to
any material size because you're too
distracted pick again do whatever you
want but I'm just saying these are these
are the most common ones and then
finally we've got no data Daddy all
right no data Papa so with no data daddy
the issue is you don't even know what
your problem is because you don't
collect any data and so it'd be like hey
what you know what do we need to grow
what's our lead cost no idea what's our
close rate no idea what's our what's our
what's our turn no idea well you can't
really do much if you have no idea
what's going on on and so this then
becomes the constraint of the business
which is we need to start collecting
data now to be clear the first five have
what I consider an impossible scenario
there's some some cost the cost here is
that you give up a business the cost
here is that you have to cut you have to
prune things or you have to hire someone
and hurt your own income here the issu
is that you have to say no to customers
that you're currently making money from
here the issue is that you have to say
no to employees you're currently
overcompensating here you have to turn
down customers at a lower price and have
and hear no more often those are the
short-term cost but the one big risk of
all is that is that your business isn't
going to grow and you've been stuck for
long enough to know it's already not
happening and there's not going to be a
silver bullet you got to confront this
the no data daty issue is just hey silly
pants get your data then you'll actually
be able to grow now there's no downside
to this one the only downside here is
that you've got some shiny object that
you think is really really sexy and
interesting and you don't get to do that
because you need to do this so do this
first and I'll give you a really useful
razor for how to think about what data
to collect to collect all right so the
easiest test for is this data valuable
is when it changes so that's a Delta so
if it goes up or it goes down does it
change that's another Delta Behavior so
if we track our views on a social media
channel if the views go up does it
change what we do if the views go down
does it change what we do if the answer
is no then we don't need to track it
because you can track unlimited
variables in the world like you can
track the temperature of the room when
when people are walking in you could
track it but will it change your
behavior you can also reverse engineer
into what are the behaviors we do what
data affects it and those are the only
pieces of data that you need to track so
my biggest personal growth lesson of the
year so I give you all the portfolio
growth things but my number one
was
Rush is
imaginary now I just gave you that whole
speech on urgency but one of the things
that is that I've had to learn is my
biggest mistakes have been sh object or
woman in the red dress and
overextension and so I have these
arbitrary goals that I set for myself
that I never say out loud that I think
about every day that mean nothing to no
one and then I try and force everything
to happen on this arbitrary timeline
that I made up and then I'm upset when
people who don't know my arbitrary
timeline fall short of the speed that I
wanted to happen even though I made it
up to begin with and so Leila gave me
this Frame that I alluded to briefly
earlier but it's probably been I would
say Talent focus and this is a subset of
focus but it's missed
opportunities is less than
problems so what I mean by that is that
the opportunities that you're looking
for are in the problems that you need to
solve and me understanding this i' I've
repeated it because it's it's really
been singed into my brain there are for
example if you're starting to get low
reviews these are things that threaten
the livelihood of the business that is a
problem if you're not doing email follow
follow up that is a missed opportunity
and unless your call it payback rate or
your LTV or some sort of conversion
mechanism is the risk of the business
then that would be a missed opportunity
if if the if the number one risk in the
business right now is that like you
can't make money because you aren't
converting a higher percentage of leads
then that would shift into a problem
it's not that like any specific thing is
one or the other it's recognizing
contextually within your business is
this something that would be nice to do
or is this something that we must do in
order for us to achieve our ultimate
goal we might be able to achieve our
ultimate goal without doing email
followup if our product sucks we will
never achieve our ultimate goal and so
it's understanding the order of
magnitude or the importance of the
potential tasks that you have the reason
that this stressed me out for so long
and this is the big one is that problems
in your business are actually finite you
can list all the number of problems in
your business by and large missed
opportunities are infinite I would look
at the world of all the things that we
could do and here's the thing is the
better you get at business the more
things you know you should be doing that
you aren't and you see this huge
unlimited potential options of things
and you look at these tiny little
resources that you have and then it's
like we need to do all of these things
and this is where you stress out your
team and you stress out yourself for
literally no reason it's been difficult
for me and it's been a discipline now to
ask myself first when I want something
to happen is this a missed opportunity
or is this a problem and nine times out
a 10 it's a missed opportunity and so
I've been doubling down on problems and
solving those the thing is is that
problems are typically not nearly as fun
as missed opportunities because missed
opportunities have all the new gloss on
them they're they're they're still in
the wrapping paper you're like oh my God
this is going to be amazing but as soon
as you get into it you're like ah
there's problems here too and then and
I've said this before but what ends up
happening is when you have this Miss
opportunity bug you you start building
all of these half-built Bridges right
you never actually get all the way
across you've got a dollar here but
you're standing on this side of the land
right and you need to get this dollar
across and you start building and then
and then you find out that there's
problems and then you're like oh no so
you know what I'm going to do I'm going
to build a second bridge and then you
find out that there's problems and
you're like oh no I hate problems I'm
going to go find another one that
doesn't have problems that immediately
just makes me more money but there's
always problems there's always problems
and so it's like I have to just use the
problems and I've got to stitch this
thing together so that I can get the
dollar all the way across and then into
my very large pocket and so here's the
difficult part of this for an
entrepreneur is that when you whatever
when you quit your job when you started
this business you were very reinforced
for pursuing a missed opportunity you
weren't doing this thing you start this
business and you get rewarded for doing
it and the problem is is that you need
to unlearn that behavior because it's a
behavior that you only want to do once
when you start your business and then
every time after that you have to
confront you have to endure you have to
stick through the problem and see it to
its natural end you have to get it all
the way there so the dollars can make it
across the bridge or you'll just have
spent all the resources all the
distraction to build and reinforce this
thing that actually results in nothing
and so this has been probably my my
single biggest tier of lesson because
this is a subset of focus for me
specifically but I ask is this a missed
opportunity or is this a problem and if
it's a problem then I need to solve it
and I just need to confront and a lot of
the problems are things that you don't
know how to solve yet that's why they're
still unsolved and so you have to become
comfortable in enduring the the failure
of working with limited information or
incomplete information because the
reality of businesses is that you will
almost always not have enough
information to know perfectly whether
this is the right call and so you have
to be comfortable in ambiguity you have
to be comfortable with incomplete data
sets and still making the call because
when you have a complete data set
there's really no stress the answer is
obvious because you have the data it's
all the times where you're like oh well
I wish I had tracked that one thing that
I didn't know is going to be important
now and I can't go back 6 months to get
it that happens all the time and you
just got to be able to make the call
because the thing is is that we have
this fear that we're leaving money on
the table right we feel like this missed
opportunity right here we're like man
there's so much money on the table but
the real money on the
table sits in the problems that you know
you should be solving but
aren't and so once I realize that the
problems are the things that I need to
be solving then I can deploy all of the
resources that I normally would use to
distract myself to reinforce this bridge
and reinforce this bridge and reinforce
this bridge before I've made a dollar go
across and then point all of those
resources to one this big dollar sign so
I can go put it into my pocket and
actually solve it and so the compounding
that occurs in business happens from
Focus it's from doing one or two things
exceptionally well not doing many things
mediocre and missed opportunities are
the gateway drug to mediocrity and how I
how I deal with this emotionally is I
have a big list of Alex's big money
ideas and I've done this at very
different times in my life life like
when I know what we need to do and we
just have to keep doing more of it and
the thing is is like you probably know
this too and yet you have this this this
need for novelty right I get it believe
me and so what I do is I add this idea
to my big money list and then when we do
have bandwidth I say what one big thing
on this big money list are we going to
attack what's crazy is I I'm like I've
got a h 100 ideas on this list and then
it's a fun problem for you to be like
okay which of these things is the
biggest thing that will get us the
furthest and what's crazy is and if you
actually do this I have found so many
times that I'm in love with an idea and
then a month later two months later I
look at that idea on the list and I'm
like I can't even believe I was so into
that right and the thing is is that if
you don't have that discipline you don't
just write on it you don't let it you
don't let it let it marinate for a
little bit sometimes you end up
deploying all these resources into
something that you a month or two later
would be like I don't even know why I
did that and if you're if this is
resonating with you right now then do
more of this put more of the ideas on a
big idea list and then just let it cook
and don't tell anybody cuz you have this
need to share you have this need to talk
the idea out loud I get it I do it just
write out as much as you need to there
and then it's like you get you get it
out of your head so you didn't have to
you got all the details and all the
craziness out and you're like I can
shove it I'll deal with it later it's
kind of like Abraham Lincoln he used to
write these letters when he's really
angry at people he'd write these huge
letters just scathing letters to these
people and then he would seal them and
then he'd put them in his desk and he
said he'd sleep on it and the next day
if he wanted to send it he could and so
his desk after years was just filled
with all these letters that he never
sent but it allowed him to get through
the moment so I want to hit on this Rush
piece CU I think this is important all
right so I'm I'm going to put these over
here to the side for a moment and Rush
is imaginary so something that I've been
thinking about is like where does this
Rush come from so fundamentally if
unless you have a network effect
business so you have a winner take all
market like you're trying to become the
Uber of whatever right there's a network
effect that one there's one winner who
will win and that's it like if you're
you're either going to be apple or going
to be Android there's no one else in the
market like you've got two spots in the
market for phone creators and that's it
that's the Monopoly right unless you're
in one of those settings which 99% of
businesses are not in that situation I
have realized that for me Rush is
actually linked to one thing which is my
competition reference point which is
fundamentally who I choose to compare
myself to and so my Rush is entirely
arbitrary because I just pick who I'm
comparing myself to now here's what's
kind of crazy do you compare yourself to
a 5-year-old do you look at a five-year
and be like what a loser they don't have
a business as big as me no of course not
right but the thing is is that why
wouldn't you compare yourself to a
5-year-old well because they haven't had
any time and because they are not
developed yet but the thing is is that
they're another human just like you and
they will eventually now like let's fast
forward 20 years now they're 25 and
let's say they're crushing it do you now
compare yourself to them why do you
compare themselves at 25 and not at 5 no
real reason because we think it's
acceptable to compete uh against that
particular ular person and so for me the
realization that Rush is entirely linked
to who I choose to compare myself to
meant that it's entirely made up in my
mind so I can just change who I compare
myself to or I could try to compare
myself less much more difficult and so
in thinking about this it's more how
does this comparison change what I do
every day and if it changes my actions
that decreases the likelihood that I
achieve my long-term goals then these
comparisons hurt me and so the question
that follows from the comparisons is how
does this serve me and if it doesn't
then why do it like do you feel guilty
in middle school that you aren't the
richest person in the world well then
why do you feel guilty at 30 I'm not
saying that's my my goal in life it's
not but like fundamentally you don't
like you don't like flipping roles when
you're in Middle School do you feel like
a loser because you're not making money
maybe a couple people right but y'all
are weird right but most people in
middle school you're like oh my God I
have you know I'm getting chest hair or
whatever the hell right you're like I'm
navigating life right now like I'm a
child look at my limbs they're longer
right and so
the thing is is that we just choose to
enter this comparison game but we're all
going to die and all of our stuff's
going to go right back into the middle
and other people are going to play with
our chips so who cares and if this Rush
is is impacting your business then you
need to find a way to quell it which is
either stop comparing change your
compare yourself to now a third door is
to compare yourself to Your Heroes at
that stage in their lives right which is
where was Warren Buffett at age 35 okay
am I on track with him but again you're
not going to be Warren Buffett because
Warren Buffett lived through the
greatest growth in in American history
and was B born at the perfect time right
and he also bought his first stock when
he was seven did you buy your first
stock when you were seven no there goes
there goes my 5-year-old analogy so if
you didn't buy your first stock when you
were seven you're not wor buff it now
you can model his behavior to have
outcomes that will be probably
proportionately smaller than his but
that's okay it's only a problem if you
think it's a problem so the next big
category of kind of growth Trends or
Focus for the year of 2025 my big
lessons was was branding so I talk about
branding a lot and that's because it's
really important but I I had a one day
where I spent with uh Ben Francis so he
came out to Vegas for the Olympia and
then we spent the day together came a
day early which is great and we just
hung out and NL Mack who's his head of
uh brand was there with him and we got
to spend a wonderful time talking about
Brandon General and they told me this
story that has really stuck with me I
got to actually connect through them
with the CMO of New Balance and so this
is the story new balance is CMO they're
both had plateaued after a number of
years and so they were kind of stagnant
and they needed to shake things up so he
became the CMO of everything and he went
to the CEO and said hey can I just swing
really big and the CEO said sure and so
then he said I want to take our spend
which right now is 70% bottom of funnel
and 30% top of funnel and I want to flip
these two things I want to make 30%
bottom and 70% top and you like what
does that mean this is is brand
awareness storytelling associations that
you make with different athletes that is
all top of funnel like wow new balance
is cool right the bottom of funnel stuff
is buy shoes right and so after doing
this what was crazy is that for the
first 18 months they made less money and
so the company's return on their
advertising budget went down for 18
months but on month 19 it went like this
Boop it started going up and then it
went up even more and then it went up
even more and so they've had this
massive rebirth from this shift and
strategy and so when I heard that story
it was really compelling for a number of
reasons for me and it changed my
behavior so number one was this is a
good ratio to think about in terms of
investing in an audience versus kind of
withdrawing from the audience and the
reason the 7030 I found interesting is
that in the $100 million leads book I
talk about this at length but there's
been a there's been a a 3:1 ratio that's
been studied by television it's been
studied by radio which is
content right to ads so if you're on
your Facebook Newsfeed and you scroll
every three posts the fourth post will
be an ad all right if you're on YouTube
it might be number of minutes now they
have ai and all this stuff but for the
the typical one it's a 3:1 ratio now
this ratio is what is required to
basically keep a brand keep a Channel
people keep coming back now if they
change this to two to1 all of a sudden
people stop watching that channel they
stop watch they switch to something else
right and so that ratio being reflected
here I see as a human thing and so I
think to myself okay I need to make sure
that I always keep my ratio at least 3
to one in terms of value driven and now
you can think about this in terms of
views like Impressions per person cuz
that's what would really matter or you
can think about this in dollar spend if
you want to think about it from a
budgeting perspective but for me I think
about this at the individual level I
want to make sure that someone's getting
at least three or four positives from
any kind before they have any kind of
ask for me to do something now the netn
net world is that if your product is
exceptional the ask is not an ask
because they're excited to buy something
else from you and so this is why brand
and product longterm are interwoven
together your reputation with somebody
will be reinforced or diminished by the
quality of the product because you make
a promise with your advertisement and
you deliver on that promise or overd
deliver on their promise with the
product and if it's worse now you got to
put more in the bucket here to kind of
like get them to be willing to take
another shot with you again or if you
have a really good product the amount
that you have to put back in here is
actually less you could sell something
else even faster so if Apple came out
with the next iPod right people would be
really excited about it and if the next
day they said hey we also have this
other amazing thing that doesn't
necessarily compete with the iPod as
long as you had the money which is a
different question as long as you had
the money or financing available you'd
be excited to buy the next thing too
provided the first thing was awesome and
so this is the idea is that products can
reinforce brand and should be the thing
that reinforc brand over the long term
which is why I want everybody to read my
books first because the books have been
the the pieces of content that I put
more single time in than anything else I
put 2,000 plus hours in each of those
books like no joke 2,000 plus hours and
so they are the single best pieces of
content that I will likely ever make and
they will outlive me these videos will
go away like podcasts will disappear but
the books will remain that is why I want
everyone to read them which is why I've
made them free like you can listen to
them on my podcast for free and if you
like hard versions you go on my site or
you go on Amazon you can grab them all
right uh they have you know 26,000 five
stars there's a million copies that have
been sold and it's because they're good
right it's and and and it's because I
put so much time into them and so this
lesson
first off was important for me because
the ratio and it corroborated what we
what I kind of already think about in
terms of content in giving to asking the
other piece that I thought was really
interesting was the time delay which is
that he made this shift and then he had
to wait a year and a half and that's
given the size budget New Balance has
which means that if you want to build a
brand you've got to expect you got to
measure in years you're not going to
build a brand in months it's just not
going to happen people see my brand now
but like my first YouTube videos also
started at zero my first Facebook page
started at zero like everyone not my
first Instagram started like at zero
like everybody else and so it just takes
time like my first YouTube videos I
think was 2019 right and so like don't
expect to have a 10-year outcome in 12
months one of the questions that I ask
myself is like okay for Branding for cpg
companies so for companies that sell to
Consumers dirting consumer The Branding
Playbook is very well tested right you
go find uh influencers in that world or
brands that are similar you do
collaborations with them you basically
cross over on values their values become
similar to yours you kind of rub off on
one another you go find Champions and
athletes that are top of their field you
make the associations people then want
to buy your product because of that
associate and the history of positive
reinforc they had with that particular
athlete okay now I was like how do I do
this in a B2B setting right and so I
have split this up into basically two
major categories if I want to build a
brand in a B2B setting right you
typically want to educate your audience
because you want to be positioned as an
authority so if you're an accountant
you're a lawyer whatever it is you want
to be known as somebody who knows what
they're doing right and so category one
is you help them accomplish their goals
for
free very simple so a lot of this is
going to be content right like this is
why we brand with content is that if you
like what's the most positive
Association someone can have they have a
goal you help them achieve it okay so
they will link their goal achievement to
your help great the next thing is that
you help someone like them so it's an
approximation which is okay I am a
lawyer and I help someone negotiate some
deal
and that person and I and I have to
advertise it I have to let people know
about it but me seeing that as a plumber
and this lawyer only helps plumbers
negotiate these deals I say oh someone
just like me got exactly what I want so
this is a degree
removed the next one is that you do the
aspirational outcome yourself now both
of these can be aspirational to be clear
and this was actually something that Ben
and I talked about a lot Ben Francis
which was often times brands are built
on the aspirational because it's almost
like an extreme version that I translate
into decreasing risk of purchase so let
me explain so Northface can help people
get to Everest and so if it's really
cold at the top of Everest if I buy that
jacket it will likely keep me warm on
the way to work from my car to the door
if Range Rover makes an ultimate outdoor
vehicle and that they're the off
ultimate off-roader then it'll probably
help me if I have to get over a curb
right it's these extreme versions that
get regressed down to well if it can do
that then it'll probably help me with my
thing right seum is the best fitness
influencer right now in this generation
and so if he wears this stuff to compete
at the Olympia and train for the Olympia
then for me to just trying to be the
strongest guy at my gym it'll probably
work for me and so the question is what
is that aspirational outcome like Red
Bull if I could iy could drink the Red
Bull and jump out of space then it'll
probably get me a little bit motivated
when I have 5 hours of sleep right like
you notice the theme here like all of
these brands have these big aspirational
outcomes there's a reason that my brand
grew when I had a $46 million exit
because it was an aspirational outcome
now what I'm trying to do now and I've
been public about that is cross a
billion dollars like that's the goal and
when that occurs my brand will be
reinforced it'll be strengthened because
it'll be an aspirational goal for more
people now the good news is a $50
million exit or $46 million exit is a
good enough occurrence for many people
now a different aspirational thing might
be our portfolio performance now we're
worth significantly more than when we
had that exit but it's less validated
it's less thirdparty signed off and when
we have that sign off it'll become
validated I'll give you a fun story on
this the amount of people that gave me
kudos for selling gym launch was
significantly more than the people who
gave me kudos for owning gym launch but
the owning of gym launch I was richer
the day before I sold the company than
the day after because the equity in the
business compounded taxfree and the
moment I sold it I had to pay taxes on
what I gained and so by definition I had
less money after the transaction than
before but everyone perceived it because
there was the third party edification
that occurred because the third party at
arms length made the transaction happen
and so it was real but as long as you
don't live in the minds of other
people's perceptions which to be fair in
branding you kind of do you don't want
your selfworth to be tied in their
perception but your brand ultimately
will be and so the idea is the question
to answer if you're a B2B business and
you're trying which is over half of
businesses are B2B fun dead I didn't
know I was looking this up for school
actually is that these are basically
your buckets is how do I help them do
what they want how do I help people like
them and how can I accomplish something
aspirational in their mind or help other
people like them accomplish that
aspirational thing and this is where
like you can help them accomplish their
goals or the aspirational goal it's
either of those things but the
aspirational one I find incredibly
interesting because some people saw the
book launch last year uh for the $100
million leads we had a gazillion people
there live it was awesome and they were
like I would like to do something like
that and so that in of itself was a
brand reinforcing event and so big
picture this is what I see as the
process for building AB Tob brand
because it's not like you're going to
like think about like this if you're the
if you're an attorney you're not going
to sign the top attorney you know O.J
Simpson's attorney I can't remember it's
the Kardashians X I can't remember what
Jenner anyways no that's Bruce Jenner
forget about it you get the idea is that
like if you a business person then it's
like elon's not going to endorse you
right it's not going to happen and so
it's like you have to do the other
things that Cano proximate your
proficiency with proof and so the final
T tldr of this is you have resources
this is what your brand must accomplish
this is the timeline that it has to go
off of this is the ratio you need to
follow and this is how you spend your
money in time to make these things
happen for the
audience and that's how you do it and so
this has been my focus uh one of the big
kind of like crystallizations of
knowledge maybe deepened uh my
understanding of branding and how it
translates back into forth between D Toc
and B2B shiron Sasa good friend of Leila
n currently the the CEO of real also has
sillo Capital which is his his uh
investment firm he gave me this little
quip that I really like and he said
Talent only gets better in the future
and that has been I mean you'll notice a
common theme around people in this and
that's because when I look at the things
that we did really well with this year
is bring good people in get bad people
out and the companies that did the best
Mor folio like that that strategy rank
fruit like the the the the the highest
performing company the portfolio we put
in probably like six great leaders and
it's just crushing and that that's not
an accident right so that's thing number
one in terms of talent the second thing
is work with the people who move towards
you and so I have spent too much time in
my life trying to sell people on why
they should do things my way or with my
values or with my kind of rules which I
Define culture as rules of reinforcement
in a business so like these are the
rules of the game as I would like to
play it and I noticed that if I kind of
have this like kind of recurring
conflict with a handful of people I was
like I don't need to do this like
there's another person who is stoked to
be here will agree with the path and
it'll be so much more efficient because
they'll want to talk to me I want to
talk to them we agree to the rules of
the game the way we both want to play it
and so we'll just play that much better
that much longer and so this is more of
like a warning shot because I think what
happens is you habituate especially if
you're an entrepreneur you have a high
pain tolerance like you're used to like
you're used to suffering suffering is
just the the current state and so
sometimes someone comes in things are
okay sometimes they change sometimes you
change whatever but fundamentally
conflict emerges and if you cannot
resolve the conflict then over time your
communication cycle lessens and lessons
you start talking less and less
frequently and if this person is close
to you or close to your function it
becomes very difficult to basically for
them to do their job and for you you to
get what you need out of the role and so
um my my single line of advice is work
with the people who move towards you and
so a a correlat second point of that
that's a different frame to Think
Through is if your team doesn't admire
some aspects of you you either have to
change them or you have to change you
like this is a tough one though because
you want like this is my opinion if your
team doesn't admire certain things about
you then the likely that you have strong
influence over their behavior outside of
basically punishment is low and it's
much better in my opinion to have a team
who admire different traits of yours now
they don't have to say everything you do
is amazing but like there are there
skills you have there are behaviors you
do that they're like man it'd be really
cool if I had that or it's really cool
that he has that or she has that and
that creates this element of respect in
the relationship that I think is really
required for high performance and you
have two choices there like either you
change or they change or you get someone
else so you change the whole thing right
I think making sure that you've
established rules of the game and just
subtly noticing like is there someone
who just like disrespects you on a
regular basis or they tried or they're
the first one to disagree I want to be
clear here I'm not saying that you
shouldn't have healthy tension and
disagreement at the top it's actually
very common like everybody who has like
different perspectives to yield the best
outcome like that's how you get truth so
that's that's good but if you're
consistently being blocked on what you
consider to be like par for course
behaviors that can grade on you and I
think that I tolerated that for too long
um and I have done that for for in
different occasions and I I want to
shorten the time that I tolerate those
kind of Dynamics so next up is sawdust
my favorite businesses in the world are
businesses that are started off of waste
from someone else so let me explain so I
love the Airbnb and I love Uber the way
that like people have excess capacity or
sawdust they have something that they're
not using that would be valuable for
someone else an easy example in a brick
and mortar scenario is like I don't use
my gym my gym was closed after 8:30 and
it was no one used it until 4:30 in the
morning and so I'm paying for this rent
and I have this space and there's
probably some people who would like to
have that space but can't right and I
didn't have you know weekend hours ended
afternoon right and so there many of us
and Airbnb did this on the residential
side obviously like you have a spare
bedroom you can let someone crash there
and you can make money for it but the
thing is is that within businesses you
also have excess capacity you have
sawdust and so the sawdust analogy comes
from Lumber Mills when they would they
would strip the Trees of bark they would
turn them into planks and then you know
they Shi the planks out but a smart
Foreman of the factory looked on the
ground one day and they had to just keep
sweeping up all this dust from the saw
and then finally one guy said hey could
we just mix this with glue and make
Plywood And then of all of a sudden a
whole new kind of industry was born from
that where you could take the scraps and
then turn into something else and in the
fur business that I did when I was 16 17
18 in there the owner would have to make
these jackets and he would cut off these
Snippets from the Snippets he was able
to make earm muffs and then he was able
to sell his ear muffs or give the ear
muffs away as bonuses and so he was able
to make something from nothing and so
there are sawdust things that exist in
your business and I'll tell you one of
the big ones that came from acquisition.
comom so our primary business is
obviously the portfolio and that's where
the majority of our resources are
allocated towards and we tried to figure
out a way where we could meet more
potential portfolio companies so I tried
a few different things to come out well
the barrier was too low we got mixy
matchy and I was like that's not good so
we tried that one and we didn't meet
good people and I was like all right
that's not good so the next thing I did
was like okay what if we raise the
qualifications really high and then we
like kind of have these dinners so we
did we did like four or five dinners
where people would fly out we'd meet
them the whole idea for me was like I
have to eat either way so I might as
well eat with people like again like
sawdust like what do I have to I also
have to make content so if I go to
dinner I make content and I meet people
this is all good this helps us generate
deals and the reason that I was trying
to figure this out was because the best
port portfolio companies we have are
number one number two number four best
performing company were companies that
we had worked with for 6 to 12 months
prior so we had an existing relationship
we had helped them grow and then we were
like okay I think their portfolio ready
now then we made our investment and we
and we grew them from there and our best
performers were like that so I was like
how can I how can I have this happen on
purpose rather than by accident so I was
I was really struggling with this mind
you I was also like running the
portfolio too so it it's like I wasn't
putting full attention towards it and
then in January I was like okay well we
have this building and we have there's
an open open floor space there were a
bunch of desks there but I was like
weren't using those desks everybody had
offices and because we do a lot of like
confidential calls and whatnot we're
more of an office closed door setup and
so we cleared the desks and we're like
okay well let's see if some businesses
would want to fly out to our
headquarters and have us spend like two
days kind of going over how we create
value because then that way it's like it
will provide value to them and the
people who are like oh this is really
cool I would love to potentially like
follow up with them over the alol they
become they kind of enter a longer term
nurture process and we can potentially
do deals with those people Etc that's
also why we spun up acq Ventures Etc and
so that whole division of workshops came
out of we have extra space and the
portfolio team isn't fully allocated
like they work on the portfolio
obviously but like they can step down
for a day or two uh during the month to
meet other companies uh network with
them share how they are turning around
different companies in our portfolio
specific divisions or departments and
that'll be very additive like we can add
value to everyone and adds value to us
add to them and I get content from it
and so that was a big W and the reason I
bring this up is there are some things
in your business that check more than
one box and so it's like I don't want a
single box check I want like four boxes
checked and so this generates deal flow
this generates cash flow this generates
content this generates Talent flow and
so all of these things and utiliz as a
resource that I already have paid for I
already I have to pay I pay this
building every month right like this
cost exists I pay my team every month no
matter what either way and so it used an
existing cost basis to create a new
opportunity for content and deal flow
and so from that it's like if you can
just look at the pieces you have on the
board and this is actually what I do I I
try and write down with as much detail
what are all the things we do on a
regular basis like what are the calls we
take what are the conferences we attend
what are the like every single thing we
do and I'm like is there a way I can
recombine these things things into
something that would be valuable at no
cost to me and that's where I've had
these really disproportionate gains in
profitable divisions or products in our
company obviously and then within the
portfolio so for example you probably
have Sops and checklists within your
business right of how you do whatever
you do well if you can take that and
then turn those into lead magnets then
not only are they valuable for you they
also generate demand and so that's just
a very micro example of like take
something you're already doing and find
another use for it that requires no
extra work the next one's really big and
so this is a little bit looking forward
into 2025 and Beyond and so I believe
this so this is a bet so ought be clear
this is H this is me making a bet and
calling a shot so I
believe that IRL and AI exist on polar
opposite sze of a Continuum and I think
that doubling down on both of these is a
good decision and So within our
portfolio we are pushing heavily on both
sides and so postco I still feel like
there's unmet demand for people who want
to connect I mean obviously this is why
I invested in school like I believe
Community is really good and I think
it's lacking right now so I think
there's huge demand for it and we've
never we've we've never been more
connected and also feel so apart and so
it's it's almost like we have a lot of
false Solutions it's like we're eating
fake food that keeps you full but
doesn't satisfy you it's kind of like
porn to sex like it's not the real thing
right and so the idea is like this is
the real thing this is efficiency and so
it's like how can I how can I get as
much efficiency as possible so that I
can do as many of the unscalable things
that are the real thing and this IRL
push that I'm doing I'm doing across all
the portfolio companies because the
interesting thing about IRL is customers
who have in-person experiences have
tremendously different brand Affinity
they're more loyal they refer more they
rate higher they buy more often and if
you have a strong culture within your
marketing or your branding you will
attract ACT like-minded people and so
that allows you to provide them value at
no extra cost so think about like this
if I assemble a party I'm the host of
the party everybody who meets at the
party feels like the the party was
awesome if everyone else at the party
was great I could not talk to any of the
guests and have them think Alex's party
was awesome and I will get a
disproportionate amount of the reward
from the associations and the time they
had but that Network allows people who
assemble to provide value to each other
which is almost like s like you're not
you you just organize it and you let
them provide the value and so IRL and AI
I'm I'm heavily pushing on this this
year Sam Alman said that this year is
the year AGI will come out 2025 so
artificial general intelligence which
basically AI is better than everyone at
everything which is frightening but
we'll figure it out in the meantime
though it'd be great if it could take
some sales calls and uh set some
appointments uh pretty accurately so uh
and maybe help with some content and
things like that uh but in the meantime
we're staying really AB breasted on this
and we're actively kind of like I'm not
trying to be the AI company I want to be
a company that uses AI well just to be
clear about my position on this IRL
though is something that I feel like AI
will not disrupt and I think that the
demand for inperson experiences uh will
continue to rise and I think that it is
a good bet to make and so this is what
I'm betting on next year and I will
mention this because a lot of people
don't like IRL because they say it's
unscalable right but I care so much more
about is it valuable and if it's
valuable enough it's worth scaling and
so the thing is is that just because
it's harder doesn't mean it's not worth
doing and the benefit of scaling
something that is harder to scale but
also valuable means that once you scale
a little bit more you'll have more
resources to continue scaling it and so
if we can build cities in the middle of
the desert or the middle of the ocean we
can absolutely scale an in-person
experience next fun one is school so
what's crazy about this is that this was
this year uh which feels like you know
an eternity ago but we uh we negotiated
the deal in 2023 and then in January we
came out publicly with it so this was
the first brand deal that I did this
year uh or sorry the first brand I've
ever done and the main reason behind
doing it was that I believed in the
product and I believed in the team and I
thought it was the best one and I think
it's going to win and so that is why I
was willing to make that bet and to be
very clear opportunity always looks like
Risk today and this this bet has proven
out very well the platform continues to
grow like crazy we have millions and
millions of users which is awesome and
that was kind of the goal and the reason
that I I ended up betting on this versus
like any other potential thing I could
do was it felt very uniquely fit for me
so I'll explain what I mean so there's a
make money component to school there's a
education component to school there's a
community component to school which I
just see as like Plus for for social
right and then all of these together
aren't an opportunity vehicle
that is high leverage and so for those
reasons I was like I feel like I am
uniquely qualified for Education media
would be another one here there's
definitely a huge media component with
the business so it's like education
media business societal good operational
leverage this was it was like if you
could make a business that hit a lot of
the things that I'm about and for me it
also help people who are going Z to one
and I have a huge percentage of the
audience that want to start start a
business don't have one and didn't know
where to go and so I wanted to have
something that I could say if you aren't
a business owner yet this is a very easy
business to get started it's very low
risk there's not many moving Parts you
can do it without any employees you
don't have to have inventory you
literally just need to learn the basic
skills and so this is a great vehicle
for doing it and so I was super pumped
uh when we found out that the average
Community made
$1,360 per month that's paid communities
and I think that's really cool because
it's like no this isn't you're not going
to be a gazillionaire by doing this but
it can help get you started and that I
see this as a great Gateway for getting
a notch ownership as a side note for
existing businesses I think every
existing business should have like every
gym owner should have a school Community
every every realtor should have a
community for their for their customers
every HOA should have a community uh a
school Community for for their for the
the people in the neighborhood like
whatever business you have like if you
have an e-commerce business there's a
ton of e-commerce businesses joining
school right now that realize that the
email deliverability like if you can
reach 100% of people who bought your
product the feedback that you can get on
the product the reviews the likely they
buy the next thing goes way up and so
it's like sure add them to the email
list but also add them to a live
community and so I see that as again the
IRL versus AI like how do we how do we
bring people together and so we're also
doubling down on that with school
because we are not we don't see
ourselves I mean obviously it's a
technology business but like it's a
community business and so we're also
doubling down on how can we facilitate
in inperson connections between people
of similar interests so I'll I'll give
you some specific lessons that I've
learned from uh growing School
tremendously over the last year so
number one is uh
cro usually decreases hold on usually
your split test will fail and so
basically the more optimized something
is the more likely a change from optimal
results in a decrease and so our first
launch of the school games page did so
well that we've done like 14 sorry 16
major split tests and only two of them
have won and so like anything from the
like so basically the control is really
really dialed and it typically like if
you have monstrous amounts of traffic
when you incur the cost of change like
it is it is a real cost the second kind
of thing that I that I would say that
like I've learned uh or rather been
reinforced from school is kind of
customers above everything which is just
always a great reminder Paul Graham has
this statement that I probably feel like
I've said a whole bunch of times this
year which is you can solve almost every
problem in a business business by
talking to your customers more like if
your marketing isn't working talk to
your customers if your sales isn't
working talk to your customers if your
product isn't working talk to your
customers right you you are never too
big to not talk to your customers and so
that that was a big emphasis the I would
say the next one is the the the value of
offers it was just you know the school
games itself was a really cool offer
that we came up with and then we added
in um you can win a cybertruck if you if
you win which which made it even crazier
and so the the uplift that a business
can get from having a superior offer we
got to see that you know it's just it's
nice to see things proven out so that
was a really good one the next big
lesson I'll put this one this is really
big is the value of deletion and
simplicity so I'll explain what I mean
here so we have tried to make it as easy
as humanly possible for people to win on
the platform and we get better and
better every day but a big part of it is
is the number one reason people cancel
things is overwhelm and so overwhelm
translates into zero value because they
stop so what happens is people hear
overwhelm and then add more stuff and so
it's it's rare that addition improves
things rather than simply making things
better or taking something out and make
and replacing it with something better
or eliminating it all together like you
want it to be as simple as possible but
no simpler right like if you if you take
away all the friction that occurs from
using a phone what's left is an iPhone
right the only next version of that
would be you just talk in the air and
then like you get connected with people
like that would be the next version of
that but what Steve Jobs did was inorder
of magnitude Improvement off of the
existing phones and he just looked at
all the things that suck about a phone
removed all of them and what was left
was the iPhone and so thinking about
product and value this way right so the
value equation you've got the outcome
you've got the risk right you've got
speed and then you've got uh you've got
you've got uh effort right so the idea
is how do we make it faster and easier
faster and easier faster and easier over
and over and over again on this value
equation and a lot of times what makes
things faster and easier is removing
things and so I have grown more and more
Affinity towards looking at what's there
and saying okay we need to maximize
value per second not seconds of value
and so this comes from the media side uh
in terms of making content but on the
product side like every customer will
ask you for different things and they
will and if you give them every single
thing they ask for they will cause their
own demise and then leave and so then
you get these Frankenstein products that
have a gazillion gizmos that no one
knows how to use because to fit it all
in it's like there's a 100 specific use
cases that don't apply to everyone and
so product discipline around keeping
Simplicity and speed and and ease as the
primary goal is an incredibly difficult
thing to focus on and making those
strategic bets and so that has been a
great Focus uh and kind of uh relearning
I would say uh of this year with school
and I would say finally having like
knowing what your what Your Loop is all
right so it's like what's your flywheel
so Jim Collins has a short book on this
called the flywheel I think or flywheel
effect and it's basically like can you
draw a circle within your business which
is first we do this which then if we do
this this is what must occur when this
happens this next thing must occur if
this occurs this next must occur right
and so I I'll show you what what what
I'm talking about so if we make a lot of
media right for businesses so we make a
lot of Business Media if we do that then
we will get business owners who Interest
Who who interested in our stuff right
and if we get business interested
business owners who are interested in
our stuff right they will then do deals
if we do deals with them we'll have
stuff to make media about and so this is
a basic wheel of acquisition. comom we
talk about business stuff that gets
businesses interested we do deals with
those businesses those businesses get
outcomes which then we talk about in the
media and so round and around we go we
want a wheel that feeds itself and so
the only thing that's required is to get
the wheel moving and So within school we
have multiple different Loops that we
have that generate the growth that
compounds within the business and these
Loops are so important because when you
have a linear input output equation in
terms of how business grows then it
means that you just have to keep adding
more on the front end what you want is
something that you spark once the engine
runs and then all of a sudden it spins
spins and goes out of control and it
just keeps growing right and so that is
the ultimate goal is having multiple of
these flywheels so a simple example is
like Amazon they create a Marketplace
that has the cheap cheapest products
that are the that have the highest
Fidelity in terms of um the risk that
someone has to make when they purchase
because they have the reviews so if they
do that then they will get more
customers if they have more customers
then they will be able to get more
suppliers if they have more suppliers
they able to get more competition in
selection for customers which then
brings in more customers right and so
round and around we go and so it's
businesses often have multiple flywheels
like this that exists that self-
reinforce and the quality of that
flywheel what you want to figure out is
what are the what are the friction
points that prevent this wheel from
spinning and then smooth it out so it
just runs so this is probably I would
say uh number five in terms of the
things that I I've gotten away from
school this year and school is probably
one of the best investments I've ever
made so this year and somewhat last year
we uh we got this great office right and
uh part of the reason we did this is
because I wanted to have a massive gym
I'm being really honest with you like I
wanted to have a really big gym which I
have and I wanted to have a place that I
could record that wasn't like out of my
house or out of a closet as much as it
is great to have my team in and out of
my personal space um I prefer it in a
studio and so uh that was the reason for
building this to begin with then we
started having a lot of teammates just
started like spending more time here and
they're like may maybe I'll move here
and so then we started to become more
and more in person as a business and so
I will remind anyone I started in person
exclusively with gyms then we went to
gym launch which was entirely a remote
business and we were entirely remote
before it was cool like we were entirely
remote when people were like you can't
be a remote business it's not legit for
real like we like we would struggle to
get like some banking relationship cuz
they're like we need to I remember there
was some software that we needed that
were like we need to see a picture of
your filing cabinet and I was like what
year is it but it's like it was
Antiquated until Co and then became the
norm and so I want to talk about pros
and cons to this because some of you
guys are business owners and you're
trying to make this decision and so
number one I think is understanding
which roles are remote and which roles
are in person so for us because we know
how to manage I think remote teaches you
how to manage better than in person does
because there's so many ancillary small
Communications that occur in person that
don't get documented remotely that still
have a material impact on the business
and so if you're only remote you have to
be very structured with communication if
you're in person you can get away with a
lot less now four roles like
fundamentally we say like why does this
person need to be here we would only
want people to be here who should be
here if you know if Finance doesn't
really need to be in the office and so
that allows us to recruit from a wider
net so we can recruit from all over the
United States rather than requiring
people to move uh or only picking from
call it Las Vegas right and so for us
the pros have been training is much
better in person culture is much
stronger uh I think you have an eye to
efficiency which to be fair is somewhat
offset with the additional cost of the
building I think that you're able to see
people in deep work and correct meeting
cadences things like that like if you're
walking around everyone's on meetings
all days you're like who's working right
uh and so this allows you to you get
faster feedback loops which I think is
important the cons of in person is that
harder attract talent because they have
to move that's a big one it's probably
the biggest one but it's easier to
attract other people though so for us
what we did to accommodate this is we
for some roles depending on the level of
the role we will also uh include signing
bonuses and things like that so if
you're in that position including more
incentive for them to move or move their
families to your place of business is a
is is a good way to do it I also
recommend having them come out for like
30 days and stay at a hotel just so that
they don't like you know deant their
whole family if for some reason it
doesn't work out kind of in the first
month you'll know and so um that's
that's like a little in between that I
think is worth doing that has worked
well for us to be to be clear for me I
think 30% of our portfolio is in person
70% of remote so I don't have I I don't
care at all about how someone chooses to
have you know structure their employee
teams I think you should just whatever
way it is I just want there to be sound
reasoning behind it and so for us
obviously we have a lot of media and so
having the entire media team here makes
sense because I film here I'm here and
so they should be here too whereas like
I said Finance it doesn't really make
sense and so it's just making sure that
like you're not being a stickler in
either direction for the sake of it and
instead just saying like what problem
are we solving and which path increases
the likelihood that it gets solved so
this year I actually made a lot of
personal improvements in terms of my
environment and I'll share some of those
with you right now and so as I was
saying earlier you know I worked a lot
more days this year a lot more hours per
day than I probably worked in recent
history and I needed to optimize more
things it's kind of like when a car is
driving at 60 miles an hour it's like it
moves a little bit when you're at 200
miles an hour tiny movement makes a huge
change was kind of the same thing in
terms of me and so with the increase in
hours the increase in days I was like I
need to get everything else dialed and
so one massive one which is going to
sound so silly is the big three of sleep
so number one is Pitch Black and when I
say pitch black I mean pitch black so
tape the little lights on all the
electronics in the room get blackout
curtains I'm telling you just do it I
took way too long to do it just do it
just do it please do it number one
number two is it's got to be cold like
it has to be super cold and if you are
in a different temperature than the
person you sleep with then get one of
those mattress pads that has the
temperature control thing it will change
your life and it will certainly change
your sleep which could very much change
your life just do it like it's it's I
think they're they're like two grand and
you spend more time in bed than anywhere
else like it's the Wellspring of Youth
it's everything like worth doing and the
third one and this is the most recent
one is that I actually added in earplugs
so I now sleep with earplugs which you
just the simple foam ones like nothing
crazy and sleeping with earplugs had a
four beats per minute drop to my resting
heart rate at the bottom of my sleep and
so I bring this up because like it had a
material difference in basically how
deeply I rest and my deep sleep is
basically very chunky and front loaded
rather than like intermittent throughout
the evening so it's like basically as
soon as I get to bed I have like deep
sleep because I hear no it's like I'm in
this black float tank essentially this
cold dark tank where I can't see
anything or hear anything and so you
you'll know when it's dark enough if
when you open your eyes and when you
close your eyes it's the same that's
where you want to be and so those are
some those are some significant ones the
next big one for me was making sure that
my work environment was basically just
as tailored and so I've usually been
better about this but I always black out
my windows because I get distracted with
good weather I just want to go outside
and so I black all that stuff out I had
two desks that I set up one for standing
one for sitting because I realized that
having a desk that moved I ended up just
not moving it cuz I didn't want to like
mess the wires up and like all the other
stuff so I just set up two desks and so
that was uh helpful the biggest pain
relief thing that I did this year
because I spent a lot of time on my desk
is I got a kneeling chair all right
which sounds ridiculous and they look
goofy but if you sit in one position all
day like I was getting really bad uh
neck pain uh like it was very tough for
me um and so by switching the kneeling
chair originally I thought I was going
to do my day in one chair half my day in
the other chair but then I realized that
when I was in the kneeling chair I
actually have like six different sitting
positions that I do in that chair and so
by constantly varying my sitting
position because as soon as I get a
little bit uncomfortable I just I just
change it up I was able to basically
decrease the resting stress on like my
muscles being in this one Frozen
position for an extended period and that
eliminated my shoulder pain like gone
and so I like really really helped me
out a lot and so I don't I don't know
what you're doing but like it was
probably like a 100 bucks and like such
high Roi for me and then the last piece
is actually around my fitness so because
I was in this very heavy season I
decrease my workouts to two a week which
is pretty light for me but I just made
those the absolutes so I basically did
Saturday Sunday as my two workout days
and I just go really hard on those days
and that's actually kind in a weird way
it's been more fun for me than trying to
do shorter more frequent workouts and so
it's actually kind of brought some like
more life back into my training even
though though I'm doing it less
frequently I'm like looking forward to
it and I realized that for me I love
training on one condition that I'm not
in a rush like I hate having to like do
a workout in 45 minutes because I have a
call like it takes all the fun out of it
for me and so I do it on Saturdays and
Sundays because I can just wake up I
will work out as long as I feel like and
then I'll start working and that's been
like really really good for me but part
of this has also been my transition U at
35 I told myself you know when I was 15
I get 35 I will I will transition to
longevity and so I have made that
transition now and so I'm like I'm
probably the lightest I've been in a
long time I'm like 203 is right now
which is very light for me for context
my heaviest I was 250 so I was very it's
all all steak um and so now I'm I'm 203
and um basically chihuahua live longer
than Great Danes uh which is small dogs
live longer and so I want to put it you
know less less uh stress on my heart and
so I'm so for those who are like Alex
looks smaller that's true cuz I am I
have lost weight I've lost about 10 or
15 pounds and so I'll probably stay
around here maybe I'll get in the high
190s but I'll probably I I maintain here
pretty easily and so that's my update on
that that part and I do think that it's
okay to have seasons like I'm not saying
I'm only going to work out twice a week
forever I'm saying I'm work out twice a
week now like I I worked out three times
this week and so it's not like I have
these rules it's just that I absolutely
committed to Saturdays and Sundays and
being a weekend warrior and that has
worked well for me to not work basically
give myself permission to do that so
that I could keep working hard on the
stuff that needed to get moved forward
so next one is culture so I Define
culture as the rules that govern
reinforcement in a business and so that
means like the rules of behavior what is
what is what is good what is neutral
what is bad and typically people have
some sort of values that they create
that are supposed to embody that culture
those values typically are you know
either phrases or they're one or two
words and you have you know three to 10
of them right and so for us I've always
believed in three because I don't think
anyone beli like remembers more than
three and if they can't remember them
there's no point in having them but
those three typically are very bucketed
terms that then need to have hundreds of
behaviors underneath them that kind of
roll into that culture it's not like you
only have three rules of Behaving you
have three concepts that have many
applications across different conditions
and so a big one that we've been
focusing on Lea and I together has been
kind not nice and so I think that in the
wake of wokeism if you will there's been
a lot of accommodation that has been
accepted tolerated within businesses
which is like everybody needs to have
these like you know safety zones and
everyone everyone everyone has to feel
hugged and fluffy and like all this
stuff and I believe that this is a
pendulum right and I think that the
pendulum swung here and I think a lot of
Brands Walmart just came out recently
rolling back some of its initiatives I
know uh Victoria Secret did last year
like a lot of them are starting to swing
back now I do think that we're going to
swing too far the other way to be clear
because that's how we do that's how us
humans do things right but I think it's
going in the right direction right now
which is going back towards the middle
and so uh within acquisition. comom we
have this big belief that we're very
good at training like we're very good at
training skills because it's something
that Lea and I pride ourselves on and
we're in this inperson environment we're
good at fast feedback loops we're very
good at breaking skills down uh into
smaller chunks to make them manageable
for somebody who's new the problem is
that sometimes that goes into no man
left behind and we are not a government
program instead it should be if you
can't keep up you can't come and so I
think this is a departure from the
traditional like all accepting let's all
all arms open like if someone you know
has like you know they don't like
working late it's like well then this
isn't for them and they can find another
job that's that that will accommodate
that but I do not because we were trying
to accomplish great things and great
things require great sacrifice and it
doesn't feel like a sacrifice to the
person who also wants the great thing it
only feels like a sacrifice for someone
who doesn't and so that price diminishes
for someone who's aligned and so kind
not nice also brings into into light
like being able to have these sincerely
canderous conversations of saying like
you are not where you need to be and I'm
going to give you a really good nug on
this is that right now you can pause
this video and I need you to show it to
your team because what they don't
understand is the difference between an
insult and you might not understand it
either and this this like changed my
life insult and criticism so do you know
the difference well I'll explain it so
an insult is where basically you slander
the other person you assign a word that
has a negative connotation so I say
something like you are lazy you are uh a
piece of you're a dick you whatever
whatever insert insert the insult you
want a criticism is the gap between
desired and actual this is a commentary
which is factual which is the
expectation is that you show up every
day by 9:00 a.m. you've shown up every
day at
9:05 therefore there's discrepancy here
in order for you to continue maintaining
your employment you need to be here
before night so this is a criticism it's
simply observing reality and if you can
do this this will allow you to help
people without having the emotional
charge now if I say you're 5 minutes
late and you're that makes you lazy or
that makes you uncommitted or that makes
you insert whatever insult it then turns
this into an emotionally charged
conversation and so what happens is and
this is why I think it's important is
that you need to explain to your team
criticism is not negative it's an
observation of reality an insult is
where we attach judgment to that
discrepancy like your content sucks
that's tough and the the secondary of
that is you suck because your content
sucks which is even harsher but instead
it says our Channel average is 100,000
the content that you make is 75,000 in
order for you to keep your employment
here you need to be above 100,000 and
now let's break down what do we need to
do behaviorally that will increase the
likelihood that you meet desired or
exceed it and so then this is where you
get to teach this is where you get to
train if someone's always late to
meetings they might not be lazy they
just might not have the skill of showing
up on time which is a skill and so you
then say okay do you set alarms how do
you estimate your time of driving do you
do it on the fastest time you've ever
driven somewhere or the slowest time
you've ever driven somewhere right do
you do it on the fastest time you've
ever gotten dressed or the slowest time
you've ever gotten dressed and so
typically when people estimate time they
usually just skew to one of these two
things there's the people who are always
way too early it's because they do worst
case on everything and then you've got
the people who are they do best case on
everything and they're always late right
so it's like how do you estimate time
and how do you set reminders for
yourself to get places by the time you
need to and so literally breaking down
that skill which seems obvious and yet
there's many young people and to be fair
sometimes old people who don't know how
to show up on time and so understanding
this and saying if we don't share this
criticism we are being nice not kind we
are not we are seeking we are seeking
contentment we are seeking approval from
everyone we are seeking consent
we're not seeking truth and so we need
to be truth seeking as a business and so
we must always State the facts and tell
the truth and if someone is not up to
Snuff we need to communicate that as
fast as possible and give them the steps
in order to remedy the situation and so
this is the part I think both of these
things get missed bosses will say he's a
dick he's lazy he's whatever and
sometimes we'll say to the person
sometimes we say behind their back both
of those are bad instead I would
encourage you to go criticism and then
steps so the way to do this is you say
tell them what to do instead so don't
just say don't do this say do this
instead of this that way you give them
directions because no one can operate on
a negative give them what to do and this
has dramatically improved my skill as an
operator with within the business and
hopefully the kind not nice is something
that you can give to your team and that
you can say is like we are here to be
kind I want to help you win but I'm not
here to be your friend and I think Reed
Hastings has a really wonderful frame
around this which is like we are
professional sport team trying to win
the World Championships we are not a
family cuz you're not going to fire your
kids you're not going to fire your
spouse you're not going to fire your
mother but if you're on a professional
sports team it's like we are all here to
win and if you don't want to win this is
not the team for you there's Triple A
there's other teams there's other teams
that are Pros that don't want to win and
that's fine but that's not what we have
here and so the kindest thing that I can
do for someone is give them clear
feedback and opportunity to improve and
if they don't improve give them the
opportunity to work at a place where
they will better fit in now that it's
been 5 years and I'm back into operating
day-to-day on the media and conversion
team that we have at acquisition. comom
it's been fun to turn things around now
I already went through the optimization
framework and that's what I executed but
the output of that was number one I
removed all meetings number two I said
you can have ad hoc uh stand-ups between
each other when you want to solve a
specific problem so I don't want to I
don't want to stop communication I just
want to stop regular wasted time blocks
that don't increase your output the next
thing and to be fair when I did all my
one-on-ones uh with every single person
in the department to understand and what
they were struggling with one of the
biggest things that came back was we're
in meetings all day we hate being in
meetings I just want to work and I was
like great let me make it easier for you
to work the next thing was uh and this
was feedback that I got from some of the
managers when they saw me running this
was they saw a framework that I like a
lot which is what who when so think
about when you have a meeting and you're
like hey we got to do this thing right
that's the what all right then a lot of
times that's it that's the meeting
everyone just goes about their step way
this the next level of that is okay this
is what it is and this is who needs to
do it so who's going to own this who's
going to own this one right who's the
the chest to chest to poke the throat to
choke all right who's the one who's
responsible now if you have what and who
that's already a better stop but where
it gets really nasty is when you put in
when and so the question that I like to
ask here is how many hours will this
take I don't ask how many days I don't
ask what day you're going to get it done
by I say how many hours will this take
and then that person will say it'll
probably take because then you get to
hear it so it's like if someone says
like 20 hours I'm like 20 hours right
but if if you ask them what day they
might be like ah today's Tuesday I can
get to you by Friday I'm like why is it
going to take 3 days right so when you
ask hours it's like this will probably
take I don't know 90 minutes I'm like
Okay cool so you can get this done in
the next 90 now they will then say well
I have them other things to do I'm like
okay what are those things and then you
get to dive in and this is fundamentally
I think the job of the boss is to
prioritize this is strategy and they're
like oh well I have this other thing
that's for this massive project and I
have to get that done I'm like well how
long does that take and they'll say okay
this many hours and say okay do that
first and then this one you can start on
tomorrow morning you'll have it done by
lunch so hit me up at noon tomorrow when
you have it done now people get scared
about this because they're like why are
you driving all these deadlines the more
deadlines you have the more
opportunities you have to say nice job I
would rather tell someone you did a
great job seven times in a week than
once a week and so I also have found
that the best performers want to work
and they hate not working and they hate
things that get in the way work they
hate office politics they hate meetings
they hate gossip they just want to work
and so I want to create an environment
for those people people and if there are
a bunch of people who want to gossip and
want to have lots of meetings and want
to idate all day amazing just not here
with the who when framework this also
gets stacked and recapped all right so
think about how a meeting runs right so
okay first thing we got to do is this
okay what is it who's got it when are
you going to get done by how long is
that going to take can I pull it up can
I pull it up can I pull it up yep that's
fine all right great next one what's the
next thing great who's going to own it
how long's it going to take great you'll
do it by this time and then so what we
do is is I will recap every one of them
every time and so by the time I've done
my fourth one they've heard one four
times two three times the third one two
times and so there's this repetition
that's gets built in and then obviously
the thing at the very end is also be the
freshest so it's like I can repeat the
least the thing that's the most fresh
and the thing that I started with which
is like way out of their mind at this
point has been repeated like seven times
and so it makes it more likely that they
will actually do it now if you want to
go the 2011 version which I had to do
for a little bit was repeat it it back
to me so I would say okay got it that's
what you're going to do say it back to
me and I kid you not if you ask him to
say it back this is crazy like one out
of three times they'll just completely
get get it wrong it's because they
weren't listening they weren't paying
attention whatever and so I'm like oh my
God I can't believe that I was about to
leave this meeting and they still they
didn't understand what they needed to do
and so you can stack the who what win
you recap it all the way through and
then if you have a team that's not doing
as well ask them have them explain it
back to you so they know what needs to
happen now once you have this Loop in
place what do we do we lubricate it we
add money we add incentives so how can
we align what they do with the outcome
of the business and so back into Ops I
looked at everything eliminated all the
meetings and then I said okay in this
department everything is based on
quality and so we just need to make
better stuff and so I said if you make
better stuff I will pay you more I'd
rather have one guy who makes three
times the money than three mediocre guys
in a very real way it's easy easier for
me to manage one person there's way less
communication there's way less overhead
way less waste and we'll get better
outcomes and so if you're like okay I
understand how you did all this but how
did you communicate with them if they
had no meetings so I just switched to a
daily standup which is every day same
time uh we all hop on and I run
departments like sales teams all right
and I think that you can do this with
any business and the reason that I like
modeling sales teams for two reasons one
I have a lot of experience with them two
I believe that the way sales teams are
structured and operated have already
been optimize for performance because
the feedback loops are so tight if
you're not managing your sales team well
you find out very quickly and as soon as
you fix how you operate it you find out
very quickly and so I think that sales
teams overall are run typically very
well now what are the things about sales
teams so for new people when they come
in what do they do they listen to a lot
of gam tape this works for customer
service this works for media this works
for sales they watch a lot of the right
way to do things then what happens
there's a lot of role playing in sales
so it's if you could roleplay in
customer service you could role playay
around what would you look at with this
piece of content what would be the
moments that you would clip out how
would you structure it and you ask them
to explain the work that they would do
that's when someone new is coming in and
then we say okay we're going to give you
a half calendar if you're a sales guy
I'm going to give you a half calendar
for your customer service I'm going to
give you a half calendar for media to
make sure you're not posting tons of
crap you're just get one post a day and
then if you do a good job you meet kpis
then you get a full calendar then I can
give you an UNCA calendar right so we
have these progressions as long as they
mean maintain their quality metrics and
so like sales we have a similar
onboarding process the Huddle process
itself is let's look at the good stuff
and let's tear about apart the bad stuff
so we' review a call that went well
great and the far more valuable let's
look at a call that wasn't that didn't
go the way it should have and we let the
person who did the call correct
themselves so it's really tough if you
go jump in and like jump down everyone's
throat and tell them why they sucked
it's much easier for them to say these
are the things that I messed up and then
the team gets to say here's all the
things you did well that that way they
get some praise from everybody else but
they still get to have that feedback and
then you can prioritize okay this is the
thing that's the most important but that
still works for customer service it
works for product it works for media
which is okay why did this clip suck and
let's look at it and if you notice a
common theme for when Clips suck then
you just repeating it and reinforcing it
keeps it top of mind we have switched to
that process and it has been very good I
also got people off the bus who weren't
aligned with it and so if you have a
change that you want to do and you
foresee that people will not be aligned
with that change then I think that you
owe it to the high performers to to
create an environment that is only other
high performance you want to get it to
the point where it's so self-managed and
self- policed that if someone comes in
and isn't holding pulling their weight
they just get removed simple as that and
the whole team comes to you like dude I
don't think this is the guy right it
shouldn't come from you it should come
from the culture of the team and that's
why you can't have a culture of
acceptance where it's no man Left Behind
like oh they're not as good as we
thought but we're just going to keep
training them we're keep deploying these
resources is not to say that you can't
train someone the question is is it
worth it so the next big theme along
operations so I'll break this into
another chunk is technical versus
management all right and so this is very
common in tech companies right you have
a an engineer who's exceptionally
talented and you want to give them a way
to move up in the company but they don't
want to manage people and in most
companies the only way to move up is to
increase the headcount that's underneath
of you and so when I saw saw this within
our company I was like this feels dumb
we should find a way for the best sales
guys to keep making more and more money
we should find ways for the best media
guys to make more more money the best
customer service UPS making more and
more money especially in the roles that
have high leverage so basically the best
content creator has more leverage than
the best sales guy best sales guy is
closer to the reward though to be fair
and so the likelihood that what they do
generates revenue is much closer whereas
marketing or content could be
significantly further away so there's a
discount that's applied there right but
big picture is is is there a track for
both types of people because there are
the people who are experts at something
you just want to let them cook and so
when I realized that the the the orgs
that I basically the divisions that I
took over the only way that someone
would win was by moving up and when you
have a the only reward structure is
people underneath of you then what does
that incentivize it incentivizes you
keeping against to yourself because if
someone gets better than you then they
move ahead of you in the in the line
number one number two is it incentivizes
the managers and the whole team to
always ask to hire more people because
if you hire more people then it means
they by default move up in the
organization the third thing is that
whoever is in charge of the promotions
and the titles becomes Chief person
whose ass we must kiss and that means
that if you it basically becomes
entirely subjective as to who gets
promoted so then the next incentive that
comes up that's perverse is you want to
show how much you're working rather than
do work which are different
and so this is where people are like if
I said what did you do yesterday and I
was like you need to give me a th000
bullets you could probably come up with
a th000 bullets you're like I tied my
shoes and then I stood up straight and
then I put one pan my right pan leg on
and I put my left pan leg on and so
people make it seem like they're just
doing all of this work but they don't
tie that work to the output of the
division and when that happens is when
you have misaligned incentives so every
one of these incentive is perverse in
that it doesn't fuel the business but it
does fuel costs with this and with the
alignance incentives the team post
change has more than doubled output more
than and so I think the lesson here and
I think that we'll probably get to
Triple or quadruple like for real maybe
I'll do an update later but this has
been a recent takeover for me the thing
is is that people typically have
significantly more output potential if
you can tap into what we call
discretionary effort which is what is
that effort above and beyond the minimum
required to keep their job so everything
above you not getting fired is
discretional discretionary effort and in
most companies there's a massive amount
of effort above not getting fired that
is unlockable if the incentives are
aligned and so many people can in a very
real way triple how much they're doing
quadruple how much they're doing only if
they're incentivized to and so when you
have a political hierarchy it just means
elbowing no one teaching each other
anything saying we always need to hire
more people decreasing your output to
lowest potential possible as long as you
don't get fired and this when coupled
with a management style of never firing
is a great way to create waste so in
order to facilitate this there typically
has to be a change in compensation so
I've talked about incentives a couple
time through here and so my goal is to
try and have everything be pay for
performance to the highest degree
possible now here's where your
operations and your Finance team will
push back they'll say This is
complicated why can't we just do it the
way everybody else does it because just
because it's hard doesn't mean it's
worth it so there's a price but there's
also a return and so all they are
talking about is the price of this thing
not what we're going to get from it if I
could then go back to that Finance
person and say hey and to be fair this
isn't me saying anything about my
finance I'm saying you might have to
deal with this hey if we were able to
quadruple our output by creating a more
complex incentive structure that might
require someone full-time just to manage
is the cost of that one person full-time
managing it worth the increased output
of 4X across the entire company duh of
course it is
but it's more complicated and it's also
worth it and so I I bring this up
because you will probably get push back
if you try and incentivize people on
performance it takes more math it takes
more tracking but I will I will say one
key part which is that if people are
going to be paid on performance my
recommendation is two things one if you
make the transition allow them to keep
their existing salaries and then add the
performance on top and then for new
people bring them in and then just have
their performance but this allows
complete adoption of the new way rapid
reinforcement Loop that that they're
like this is way better and then
ultimately if you make the jumps in comp
proportional to the output that you seek
to get then you will still make more
than the cost so it's like going it's
going to the store buying 3x output at
twice the price of your 1X it's still a
better deal even though it costs more
around this pay for performance it will
also very clearly demonstrate who is
really good and who isn't and I haven't
really talked about like letting people
go who are low performers I'll just only
say this one word about it which is
bloat is like cancer in a business or
it's like weeds in a garden is that
bloat naturally occurs people hire more
people because the simplest solution is
throw money in bodies at stuff and it's
often not the right one you have to keep
your garden healthy by pruning it by
deweeding it you keep a tree healthy by
cutting off the Stray branches that are
growing in the wrong direction because
it's detracting from the growth of the
overall trunk and so this is the part
that that is that is probably contrarian
for most of you fire when things are
good not when they are bad so when
things are good is when you have the
most bloat and so it is far better to
let people go at that point for low
performance because it doesn't feel like
the company's losing feels like we're
being disciplined if you let people go
only when the company performance drops
it feels way worse having done both I
strongly recommend the other so for
example we were very fortunate but
during covid prior to co we had been
very militant about making sure that we
were making sure that everyone was
efficient and that the that the
headcount made sense based on the demand
and so when Co hit we had very minimal
amounts that we had to change internally
in the business and so because of that
um I think it was able to maintain
morale relatively well during a time
when my industry was getting destroyed
and there's a number of ways you can do
pay for performance and you don't need
to have as much performance as you might
think in order to incentivize action and
so if you're like I don't have budget
for that that's okay just just make a
couple tiers or performance and then you
can have flat bonuses by hitting some
tiers like you can I mean literally it
doesn't have you don't have to think in
percentages it can just be flat amounts
based on based on tiers and I think it's
a very good structure and a good way to
test this out is once you figure out
your your compensation thing that you
want to do back test it so just look at
what it would have been the month before
and then see what it is and if that
makes sense then it's like cool well I'm
going to assume the performance is going
to go up if I pay for that added
performance and am I okay with this
increase and if so which if you align it
with the incentives of the business it
should more than pay for itself the
structures that I'm talking about with
the sales team management functions best
in my opinion when you have teams of
similar function what that means is like
an executive team is going to be very is
has many people with very different
functions and expertise a customer
service team has many people with the
same function and expertise and so this
style of management of you know reviews
uh onboarding huddles what did we what
could we do better here those are great
when everyone does the same thing if
everyone does different things you will
have a different structure of it's far
more round table where everyone's more
or less updating and then coming with
the discussion topics that affect
everybody else and problem solving
together more than upskilling together
so that's really probably the main
difference between those is one is like
we're really solving problems together
for the majority of time not that you
don't do it the other way but the
majority of time we're solving big
problems with disparate teams or
different teams diverse teams and then
with similar teams homogeneous teams is
typically upskilling together and
aligning priorities so oh man this is a
big one problems and solutions have
delays all right so hear me out on this
right now you are living with problems
that you created 6 months ago and when
you begin to implement Your solution the
problem will not immediately go away and
so there will be this period of time
where you're executing a solution on a
problem that you cost 6 months ago and
you will still continue to live with the
problem because the solution has not
borne fruit yet it hasn't latched in yet
it hasn't come to fruition and so you
have to give Solutions the amount of
time they deserve to work before
appraising whether or not they worked to
begin with which I recommend doing prior
to implementing the solution so
basically when you're about to do
something to fix some problem say how
long do I think this should take before
I can say if it worked or not and then
stick to that because in the moment you
will only incur even more cost which is
why it's so painful it's like you have
this problem and now you're incurring
more cost to try and solving it and and
you're still suffering the problem and
the cost of solving it without the
benefit and so this is kind of the
endurance part of Entrepreneurship is
that you have to keep working without
seeing the result of your work you don't
need to change anything you need to
learn to endure because just because
it's not working doesn't mean you're not
on the right path and so the easiest way
to think about this is like if you were
to go to the gym and you start working
out and you start eating better you're
50 lbs overweight that problem was
created years in the past you now
incurring the solution is incurring the
problem you're still overweight and the
cost of the solution which is now you go
to the gym now you're not eating the
foods you like whatever but you're still
overweight and so after 7 days you might
think okay well I should stop doing this
because it's obviously not working you
have to give time time for the solution
proportional to the size problem it's
solving and if you don't approach it
this way and you ignore your problems
when you scale you scale your problems
with you which means that this is why
I'm such a believer in solving the
problems in order to scale rather than
scaling despite my problems because then
it just makes my problems bigger hairier
and nastier and so if you're living in
good times right now you can't rest on
The Laurels because it's not from the
work you're doing today it's from the
work that you did 6 or 12 months ago and
this has been a constant reminder for
Laya and I when we go through things
when things are good we're like what did
we do 6 months ago that is causing this
and if things are bad we ask what did we
stop doing or what did we add in in the
past that created this too often we look
at today and think that our bad days is
because of what we did yesterday and it
often isn't and so properly attributing
where the cause of the solution or
problem came from can give you the
outside return that you're probably
looking for and I'll give you this very
tactical tip if you see a a decline and
performance in a division or a function
of the business you'll it'll typically
look like this so let's say let's say
that you know you've got this div let's
say it's lead flow whatever and then it
starts flatten out and then it starts
going down right so you notice right so
what happens is people wake up here and
say we don't have enough leads right and
so they say okay well show me the ads
this week show me the ads last week so
the question is what ha like where do
you go do you go
here or do you go here
go here why did we stop growing not why
did we start shrinking and so you have
to look at where the Delta first
occurred and then what happened in this
what happened leading up to here what
did we change often times it's a who and
here's a fun one a lot of people think
oh we must have lost someone key most of
the times you added someone you added
someone
terrible I'm dead serious we had uh we
had an issue where our uh our Ascension
rates all of a sudden sudden like I know
I was like why are Ascension you know we
started looking at all these different
we looked at did all the functions we
looked at messaging all this stuff and
finally I was like and Lila brought it
up she's like let's just look at the
month when they stopped going up we
looked at that month and we looked at
what had happened the only change that
had happened was that we had hired a new
head we added
someone to do the job and by adding this
bad person they destroyed the function
and like sometimes it's a house sometime
sometimes you change your process and
sometimes that's the culprit but a lot
of times you added someone who actively
is destroying your business so another
big lesson of this year was around
content and so I made this video called
back to business I don't think it was
called that was basically we did this
experiment for 16 weeks where we made
very very wide content so like you know
meals and workouts and Vlogs and things
like that where we wanted to see okay
well if we get more views then maybe a
percentage of those people will be
business owners and so we our relative
amount will go down that are business
owners but our absolute amount will go
up and so that's all I care about is the
absolute amount and so it turns out that
that hypothesis was wrong at least for
us and so when we made wider content we
had fewer absolute amount of business
owners who were opting in who were who
were buying the books and so for me Book
Sales is actually a very leading
indicator for the people who we want
coming towards acquisition. comom and so
uh and email options on the site that's
a big one by the way if you're not
subscribed to mosy uh mosy money minute
it's one of the best things that I put
out there it takes a minute and I
deliver two every week that are
extremely tactical things that you can
immediately use to make more money like
very tactical what of the best things I
put out there so I think you go to
acis.com
newsletter and it's there so you can opt
in grab that I I think you will like it
it's very good I put a lot of time into
it okay back to business so in finding
that out we shifted our content indeed
back to business and lo and behold we
got more business owners crazy but I
think this is important because a lot of
us fall into this wide views vanity trap
and so being clear about why you're why
you're making content to begin with is
important if you're a business owner and
you're making content because you want
to make more money then you need to stay
on point serve the Avatar you serve and
that has served us very well especially
in the longest forms content I think the
shorter stuff you can get away with what
I would consider adjacent if you're a
salon lady and you sell haircuts I know
I'm butchering this but you get the idea
then if you talk about beauty in general
you will probably attract the type of
Avatar who spends money on these types
of things and so I see that as okay but
if you're going to do a long video
probably don't do it on makeup tutorials
if you sell haircuts get the drift so
another big part of this is that the
structure of the content for
entertainment is not the same as uh as
education and so with
education a lot of the effort is in the
pre-production with ENT entainment a lot
of the effort goes into post- production
there's obviously pre as well but the
post production there's just God like
think about making the Transformers
movie how much post-production is there
in that movie a ton right whereas some
of the top education videos on the
internet are just a dude with a
whiteboard which just goes down to the
quality and the Simplicity of the
content itself and so you can make
something significantly more compelling
by making the language more readily
accessible to your avatar now two compon
to this one is the examples that you use
you want it to be as relevant to the
Avatar as possible if I'm talking to uh
you know a bunch of mechanics then I'll
probably make a car analogy if I want to
talk to a bunch of ladies I might use a
cooking analogy right and that's with
traditional gender roles and stereotypes
deal with it all right and so the idea
here is I will try and speak in a way
that I think has the highest likelihood
of being language that will be
comprehended by the widest slice of my
target audience now if you have an even
broader audience then you would limit
the amount of analogies to things that
everyone understands so probably be
human things so I might be talking about
just eating in general sleeping in
general brushing your teeth in general
would be the analogies that I would use
and the grade language of my speech
would be as low as humanly possible so I
looked at this politics thing this was
before this election but they had shown
that the politician that spoke at the
lowest grade level won every election
now I don't know if that's held true
since then but I thought it was
relatively telling with all of these
different marketing strategies the one
that mattered most was actually being
understood which leads into one of the
biggest next things that we did which
was I'll put pre versus post here uh
which for us because we're education we
are focusing more on pre-production this
video right now we prepared for hours
like what are all the lessons I have
what are the examples I want to talk
about like this isn't me just turning on
the camera and saying like what's up I
actually put a lot into this and because
I it was a whole year it was also
helpful for me CU I like to crystallize
my own knowledge but prsus post and then
another one is is clear packaging right
is just be very clear about what it is
your content is about and what they're
going to get from it and so from that we
came up with the three PS which is
proof
promise plan and so every introduction
of every video has to have these three
things now it doesn't have to but we
found that when we included those things
those videos did better and so you
notice every video since this back to
business theme we have proof promise
plant within the first call it 30
seconds and so it's what are you going
to get from the video why should you
believe me and this is how we're going
to do it and so in this video I started
with we have these three companies uh
you know three of our companies are over
100 million we sked a lot this year we
went from you know 50 million in eida to
just under 100 you will learn the
lessons from this so you can apply to
your business and the plan that we're
going to do it is I'm going to walk
through them step by step all right
there we go right very straightforward
and the last piece which was a small one
which I actually got pushed back from my
team on which is why I'm sharing it with
you is introduce yourself
right so a lot of people are like oh we
don't want to introduce like my audience
knows who we are well good thing you're
not just making it for them you're
making it for people who don't know who
you are yet right and so what we did is
that we've actually now Consolidated
this to lower third and so at the
beginning of this video you should see
you know Alex rosi manage your partner
acquisition. comom so we actually able
to cut that out of me saying it because
we wanted to keep the intros really
tight but if no one knows who you are I
also have taken out the uh hey if you
don't know who I am just say I'm Alex
I'm the managing partner of ais.com this
is what we do or put it lower third and
then just skip forward right you you
want to keep it as tight as humanely
possible and when we look back at the
videos that did exceptionally well these
were the things that these were our
common themes we put more in Pre we
introduced ourselves we made it very
clear packaging we had a prooved promise
plan that was laid out we had examples
that were clear and relevant to our
Avatar which is business owners and so
we made content about business and lo
and behold it has been good and on a
personal note I prefer making business
content to not business content I like
resented I'll be really real with you I
I was so H I was afraid of the results
that were going to come in cuz I was
like if I'm going to have to make Meal
videos I'm going to kill myself I just
like I like like then we'll do our
workouts next I'm like no I'll just I'll
just be dead it won't matter like it
doesn't matter I'll just die and so and
so like I'm sure from like the thing is
is that I have a relatively High pain
Toler so like if it was the way to win I
would like if you were like hey if you
hit your hand with this Hammer your
business will keep growing like my hand
my hand would be a pancake right I would
just keep going at it but I I would
prefer not to do it that way and I'm
very grateful that you guys like
business concept better because that's
what I like making too so the next one
is around platforms and I think this was
really interesting so I looked really
deeply at the platforms from this last
year and so I made a whole tier list
video about this so I'm not going to go
in super depth on this but I would say
that the uh MVP of the year was email or
maybe most improved if you want to call
it that way I have not traditionally
spent a long time on email which seems
ridiculous cuz written word is my best
format duh and so I started writing
emails and they started doing well duh
like maybe I should hate money less I
don't know anyways so email was kind of
the MVP of the year for me probably the
the like the most improved like didn't
expect it the feedback I've gotten has
been exceptional and I made also a
separate video on how I just write my
emails and so you can watch that I'm
sure it'll be I'm sure you can find it
all right beyond that though Facebook
was a uh in terms of like book sales per
follower count and per view count was
kind of like the highest leverage like
we actually got a lot from that so we're
investing more in Facebook right now The
Perennial Champs were IG and YouTube uh
in terms of percentage of traffic that
came to acquisition. comom YouTube
Instagram were by far the biggest ones
the unbeknownst one was books this is
one that no one talks about but Amazon
is actually responsible for like 15% of
my traffic uh which is kind of cool
meaning basically the amount of people
who buy books and then read the books
and then go to the site a huge
percentage of my traffic indirectly
comes from Amazon because they because
my books do really well and have a lot
of reviews and and Amazon wants to have
people buy products that they like on
Amazon because then they associate the
good things from that product with
Amazon ha right it's like they have a
strategy and I also said in my tier list
video that Tik Tok was something that I
uh was deprioritizing and I thought more
about that since that video so it's been
like seven months I think since I made
that video I think that it's not that
Tik Tok is not a good platform for
business I think that we had a skill Gap
around Tik Tok and so I'm actively
trying to remedy that right now and
bringing in some amazing people I'm from
the Tik Tok side it's a platform I don't
know very well and so we are going to
just bring in great people and in line
their incentives and see what happens
but fundamentally I know there are
business owners on Tik Tok I just
haven't been able to package my content
in a way that did well on that platform
but if you're curious since we made the
incentive change our Tik Tok is up 300%
this week so you know incentives work
and speaking of those platforms I would
recommend checking out my email I did
say it earlier uh MIM moneyy minute I
put a lot of time into them I think
they're really good uh if you like my
books you love the emails it's like like
super super distilled down that really
proud of them it just it's just worked
out really well and so I think um I
think you will like them uh it's
acis.com newletter and by the way if you
haven't read the books for the love of
God it's the best stuff I have so like
if you like my videos you will like the
books more straight up you'll like them
more they're better and I feel like I
can say that objectively like I work on
both of them and I think that and it's
just fundamentally it's because I
haven't spent 2,000 hours on a video I
have SP $2,000 on a book so $100 million
offers $100 million reads check them out
if this was valuable for you it would
mean the world to me if you shared it
with another entrepreneur or people
inside of your team it's the only thing
that encourages me to keep doing this as
I shout into the dark abyss share it on
your stories text it to friends it it it
would mean a lot I don't have sponsors
for this thing and so that is my only
ask otherwise stay awesome